I'm alone, but a pity I won't be soon In New York City, when I see you.
我独自一人，不过在纽约市见到你时，这种孤单就不会持续太久了。
Please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
请允许我在纽约市把一切都告诉你。
Well hello out there, welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother where I, Josh Radner, I'm talking to my friend Craig Thomas, who's here right now.
各位听众好，欢迎收听新一期的《老爸老妈的浪漫史幕后》，我是乔什·雷德纳，正在和我的好友克雷格·托马斯聊天，他就坐在我身边。
I'm staring at him, hi Craig.
我正盯着他看呢，嗨，克雷格。
I'm right here.
我就在这儿。
It's true and Greg co-created a show called how I met your mother with Carter Bays that I start on from 2005 to 2014 we're making our way through each episode.
没错，格雷格和卡特·贝斯共同创作了一部名叫《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的剧，我从2005年到2014年一直担任主演，我们现在正一集一集地回顾这部剧。
We're deep into the second season Today we're discussing episode what what episode of this is the second season's episode 16 number 16 Sweet 16 this episode is called stuff.
我们已经深入到第二季了，今天我们要讨论的是哪一集呢？这是第二季第16集，第16集，美好16岁，这一集叫做“杂物”。
It was written by are the great Courtney Kang, Cocoa, Cocoa, Cocoa, Cocoa, all of us here, and Alec, tell us when this episode aired.
这一集是由伟大的库尔特妮·康、可可、可可、可可、可可，我们这里的每个人，以及亚历克共同编剧的，亚历克，告诉我们这一集是什么时候播出的。
This aired on February 19th, 2007, and I'm pretty sure if you're listening to this today on the day it dropped, it is February 16th or so.
这集是在2007年2月19日播出的，而且我敢肯定，如果你是在它上线的今天收听这期节目，那就是2月16日左右。
So close.
太接近了。
All surrounding right there.
完全对上了。
Don't worry about it.
不用担心。
But yeah, we're almost, we're almost exactly in time.
不过确实，我们几乎，几乎时间完全对上了。
So we're They're officially 19 years ahead of each episode as they are.
所以我们它们正式提前了19年播出，就像每一集那样。
Almost to the day.
几乎不差一天。
That's how we designed them.
这就是我们设计它的方式。
The minute.
分秒不差。
Totally.
完全是这样。
It's got a 19 year purpose.
它有着19年的宏伟目标。
Lucky number 19.
幸运数字19。
What a weird number.
多么奇怪的数字啊。
That's round number 19.
是个整数字19。
If you met someone in their favorite number was 19, you'd be like, what are you talking about?
如果你遇到一个人，他最喜欢的数字是19，你肯定会想，你在说什么呢？
What are you talking about?
你在说什么啊？
Anyway, so this episode, Craig, this is a, we talked about it.
不管怎样，克雷格，这一集，我们讨论过了。
It's a bit of a lighter episode, however, it has a couple of things in it that I think it become like weirdly iconic both for the fans and also I got to say there were a couple things that I had forgotten they were in this episode that were on set hilarity.
这算是一集比较轻松的剧集，不过里面有几个细节，我觉得对粉丝来说变得莫名其妙地具有标志性，而且我还得说，有几个细节我甚至都忘了它们在这集里了，片场当时可太爆笑了。
Oh, yes.
哦，是的。
Okay.
好吧。
So I think top half fish bottom half humid, like the mermaid question is kind of entered the, the how, how I made your mother lore.
所以我觉得上半身是鱼下半身是人，类似于人鱼的问题，已经进入了《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的传说中了。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, definitely.
对，绝对是的。
That's the, we, we bring it back throughout the series.
我们在全剧中都多次重提这个梗。
It's a big debate.
这是一个巨大的争论点。
And I gotta say, if you said, you know, gun to head, what is your, what episode was that in?
而且我得说，如果你问，假设拿枪指着你的头，那是哪一集？
I'd be like, I have no idea.
我可能会回答，我毫无头绪。
I have no idea.
我完全不知道。
I remember the bit.
我还记得这个段子。
I remember the argument.
我还记得那个争论。
Well, the weird thing is many seasons later, we did an episode called the mermaid theory.
奇怪的是，好几季之后，我们拍了一集叫《人鱼理论》。
That's about something completely different.
那一集讲的是完全不同的事情。
We have a whole other mermaid thing that has to do with mistaking manatees for being mermaids because it's a bunch of dudes out at sea and on a boat and they're so starved for women that that's the genesis of mermaids.
我们还有另一个关于人鱼的设定，把海牛误认成了人鱼，因为有一群男人出海在船上，他们对女人极度渴望，这就是人鱼传说的起源。
The idea that if you will start to hallucinate if you're sort of lonely and imagine mermaids where there are manatees, that's like many years later in a whole, we were obsessed with mermaids for some reason on the show.
这种想法是，如果你有点孤独，就会开始产生幻觉，把海牛想象成美人鱼，那是很多年以后了，而且整整一季里，出于某种原因，我们对美人鱼着了迷。
That's what I've discovered.
这就是我发现的。
Would you say that Splash was a formative influence on you and Carter?
你会说《美人鱼》对你和卡特产生了深远的影响吗？
Apparently, because I'd kept coming up.
显然是的，因为这个梗一直在出现。
Splash is a freaking great movie.
《美人鱼》真是一部超级棒的电影。
Yeah, that's in there, that's in the, that's in the mix.
对，它就在其中，在我们的灵感库里。
Yeah.
对。
So what were your, what were your thoughts when you, when you revisited this episode?
那么，当你重新温习这一集时，你有什么想法？
Do you watch all the episodes with Rebecca?
你每次都和丽贝卡一起看所有的剧集吗？
Yeah.
对。
And also sometimes we jump ahead, you and I, when we're, we have to record something out of sequence and she refuses to do it.
而且有时候我们也会跳着看，你和我，当我们不得不跨集录音时，她就拒绝这么做。
Yeah.
对。
Cause she's having lunch with my wife and they're complaining about us jumping ahead.
因为她当时在和我老婆吃午饭，她们还在抱怨我们跳着看。
I know.
我知道。
You said Jordana have the same thing and she won't, she refuses to do it.
你说乔丹娜也是这样，她拒绝这样做。
She just wants to go sequentially and I respect that.
她只想按顺序看，我非常尊重这一点。
So sometimes I jump ahead to watch one, and then I have to rewatch it when she and I then catch back up to it.
所以有时候我会跳着看某集，然后当她和我重新追到那一集时，我又得重看一遍。
So there's certain of them that I'm watching twice.
所以有些剧集我实际上看了两遍。
But she thought this one was really funny.
但她觉得这一集真的非常搞笑。
She said, this one's just a joke machine.
她说，这一集简直就是个笑话制造机。
That was her take.
这就是她的看法。
She's like, this is just a funny little joke machine.
她觉得，这就是一台搞笑的小段子制造机。
And it's true, it's very funny.
确实如此，非常搞笑。
I think it's a really funny episode, a lot of great moments, but it's light and it's silly, a lot of stupid stuff.
我觉得这是一集非常搞笑的剧集，有很多精彩的时刻，但它很轻松，也很荒诞，有很多无厘头的东西。
I love the series arc thing of continuing to slap that.
我喜欢贯穿全剧的连环巴掌梗。
I love the bravado of, when I was rewatching it, I was thinking, oh, well, I remember it ends with slap number two, when Neil's dressed as a crazy tin man like robot.
我喜欢那种孤注一掷的感觉，当我重新看的时候我在想，哦，我记得这一集以第二记耳光结束，当时尼尔穿着一个疯狂的铁皮人机器人服装。
I remember that image so well on how funny it was, but I thought, oh, we must remind the viewer about the slap that, right?
我对那个画面以及它有多搞笑记忆犹新，但我想，哦，我们必须提醒观众关于那个耳光的事，对吧？
There's many episodes between this episode, you know, when we set that up in this Robin Sparkles episode.
这一集和我们在那个罗宾·舒巴斯KTV集里埋下伏笔之间，隔了很多集呢。
And the whole episode I'm watching last night going, when are we gonna set that up?
结果我昨晚看的时候整集都在想，我们什么时候才会提起这个？
When are we gonna remind the viewer?
我们什么时候才会提醒观众？
And then I remembered the bravado of, we just didn't say a fucking word.
然后我想起了那种大胆的做法，我们丫的一句话都没提。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
And at the very end, he just gets the shit slapped out and Marshall just goes, that's two.
然后在最后，他直接挨了狠狠的一巴掌，马修直接来了一句，“这是第二个。”
And if you missed that other episode, three months earlier, you're like, what the fuck just happened?
如果你错过了三个月前的另一集，你肯定会想：刚才到底发生了什么鬼？
But there's, I gotta say, I kind of respected this one.
但我必须说，我挺佩服这一集的。
I know, the literal thing.
我知道，字面上的意思。
And the medical thing.
还有医疗方面的事。
The literal thing.
字面意思。
We didn't say that.
我们可没那么说。
Yeah, it's funny also in the kind of moral universe of how I met your mother.
是的，在《老爸老妈的浪漫史》这种道德宇宙里这也很有趣。
Like Barney deserved to be slapped right there.
就像巴尼当场就该挨这一巴掌一样。
I think it's slapped.
我觉得他挨打是活该。
He absolutely merited that slap.
他绝对配得上那一巴掌。
What else in this episode struck you?
这一集里还有什么让你印象深刻？
Excuse the pun.
原谅我用双关语。
My sense memories of watching the episode where I remember how satisfying it was.
我观看这一集的感官记忆是，我记得当时感觉有多爽。
Barney was such a dick when he got the shit sucked out.
巴尼在挨揍的时候真是个混蛋。
I'm kneeled in an amazing fall.
尼尔摔得太精彩了。
He had another great meal, physical comedy moment.
他又贡献了一次精彩的形体喜剧时刻。
How satisfying that was.
那是多么令人大快人心啊。
But I remember the other visceral thing, but I remember you talking about it at the time and reminding me over the years and kind of hating me slash Carter slash whoever wrote it for, Courtney Kang, I guess, to, you said, getting licked on the face by various dog actors was really not a high point for you.
但我还记得那种直观的感受，我还记得你当时说起这事，这些年一直提醒我，而且有点恨我/卡特/或者任何写剧本的人，我猜是库尔特妮·康，你说，被各种狗狗演员舔脸对你来说真的不是什么高光时刻。
Oh yes, that was the worst, that was one of the worst things that happened to me on how I met your mother was getting licked on the face.
哦，是的，那是糟糕透了，那是我在《老爸老妈的浪漫史》里经历的最糟糕的事情之一，就是被舔脸。
I remember you saying at the time, you came up to me after the take.
我记得你当时拍完后走到我面前说。
And because I was on set, I think for that one, you said to me, my face still smells like drying saliva right now, Craig.
因为我当时在片场，对于那一幕，你对我说，“克雷格，我的脸现在闻起来还是一股风干的口水味。”
You guys did this to me and I'm not, I won't soon forget it.
你们对我做出了这种事，我不会轻易忘记的。
You were really unhappy with that, and I am sorry.
你当时真的很不高兴，对此我很抱歉。
I was really unhappy, yeah.
我确实很不高兴，没错。
There was no way for me to kind of like, stiff up or lip that, that.
我根本没办法忍住或者无视那种感觉。
Like, I was really, I really hated it.
就像是，我真的很，我真的很讨厌它。
Upper lip was getting licked by a strange man.
上唇被一个陌生的男人舔着。
And it's also funny, like, one of the challenges we had, and I had to reveal this to you right after I was cast, was I'm allergic to dogs.
而且这也很好笑，我们遇到的其中一个挑战是，在我刚被选中后不久，我不得不向你坦白，我对狗过敏。
I mean, I am very public about, I have a labradoodle now named Nelson, who has my whole heart, and he doesn't make me sneeze, is hypoallergenic, but my whole life have been very allergic to dogs.
我的意思是，我很公开地表示，我现在有一只名叫纳尔逊的拉布拉多犬，他赢得了我的全部爱心，他不会让我打喷嚏，是低过敏性的，但我的一生对狗都非常过敏。
And then I get cat, it was basically like me getting cast on a Western.
然后我得到了猫，这基本上就像我在一部西部片里被选中一样。
You're like, you ever had a horse?
你就像是，你骑过马吗？
And I'm like, I can't do it.
而我就像，我做不到。
But you know, Robin had these five dogs.
但你知道，罗宾有这五只狗。
And I was like, I'm also allergic, I realized to strange men, day players coming in and licking me on the face.
而我就像，我还过敏，我意识到对陌生的男人，客串演员进来舔我的脸。
I didn't know that that also.
我不知道这也是。
It's a rare allergy test.
这是一个罕见的过敏测试。
They can test for it now.
他们现在可以检测出来了。
Your skin will just blow up.
你的皮肤会直接肿起来。
I'm glad we're raising awareness for it because it is a real thing.
我很高兴我们能提高对它的认识，因为这确实是一回事。
Well, it's a great bit of the, so the gist of this episode, why don't you tell us the kind of inciting idea for this?
嗯，这是个很好的片段，那么这一集的主旨，你为什么不告诉我们这背后的启发想法是什么？
We didn't even do this.
我们甚至都没做这个。
Right, we didn't even do our little, oh yeah.
对，我们甚至都没做我们的小开场，哦对。
I mean, the philosophical symposium of this episode, I do love a good, this falls under the Hennium category of like philosophical debate, go some episodes, a little mysteries, this one is just a symposium on, when you're in a new relationship, the way Ted and Robin are in this episode.
我是说，这一集的哲学座谈会，我真的很喜欢，这属于亨尼姆类别的哲学辩论，有些剧集讲点小悬念，这一集只是一场座谈会：当你处于一段新恋情中时，就像这一集里泰德和罗宾那样。
Are you to pretend that you've never once been with another person before this person?
你是要假装在这个人之前你从来没有和另一个人在一起过吗？
Are you supposed to act like that's the universe only revolves around this one person?
你是要表现得好像宇宙只围绕着这一个人转吗？
Or do you acknowledge all the other human beings that you had feelings for and you dated and all that's why it's called stuff.
还是你要承认所有其他你曾对之产生过感情、曾与之约会过的人类，这就是为什么它被称为“旧物”。
It's about the things, the things we keep from previous relationships.
它是关于那些东西，我们从以前的恋爱关系中保留下来的东西。
And I really love the twist in this episode that when we think it's all about the stuff The Ted has been given by various women, and then it turns out Robin has these living, breathing things that represent her previous relationships.
我真的很喜欢这一集的反转，当我们以为这完全是关于泰德从不同女人那里收到的东西时，结果证明罗宾有这些代表她过去恋爱关系的活生生的东西。
They're the boyfriends that she got dogs with, which is also insane, by the way.
它们是她和前男友们一起养的狗，顺便说一句，这也是疯狂的。
We didn't spend enough time in the episode being like, how many dogs, how many, how many date these guys that you got dogs with?
我们在这一集里没有花足够的时间来讨论，到底有多少只狗，有多少个，你跟多少个约会对象的男人一起养了狗？
It feels pathological, like every boyfriend there's a dog that's involved.
这感觉有点病态，就像每个男朋友都扯上了一只狗。
It does, we skipped over that really huge question, I guess, can we maybe?
确实，我们刚刚跳过了那个非常巨大的问题，我想，我们可以吗？
I also think there's something funny about, they keep going back to the booth and back to the gang.
我也觉得有个挺有意思的地方是，他们一直回到卡座去找那帮朋友。
It feels like they're visiting like the oracle of Delphi or something where they're just like we're like we have another riddle We have another question.
感觉他们就像是在拜访德尔斐神谕什么的，就好像他们说，我们又有一个谜语，我们又有一个问题。
You have to help us solve this Yeah, totally and I love that.
你们得帮我们解开这个谜题，是的，完全是这样，我太喜欢这样了。
I mean that that's kind of a long-running tradition of him and where it's like we're gonna put it to the group Yeah, they're they're having huge arguments between the two of them and they say the only way to solve this is the group And there's something kind of nice about that the high the hive mind of the five together They'll they'll get some and you know you can expect like Lily's gonna kind of answer one way Barney's gonna answer another way Even though this episode is a joke machine, the underlying kind of philosophical question that you just laid out is a really deep and serious question that I think anyone who's dated more than two people has had to go on your face.
我的意思是，这算是他和她之间一个长期以来的传统，就是说我们要把这事交给集体决定。是的，他们俩之间爆发了激烈的争吵，然后他们说解决这个问题的唯一办法就是找集体评判。这种感觉其实挺不错的，五个人的集体智慧聚在一起，他们总会得出一些……而且你知道，你可以预料到莉莉会从某个角度回答，巴尼会从另一个角度回答。尽管这集就是一个笑话制造机，但你刚才提出的那个潜藏的哲学问题，其实是一个非常深刻、非常严肃的问题，我想任何约会过两个以上的人都会深有同感。
Yeah, and Marshall and Lily are the exception.
是的，马修和莉莉是个例外。
Yeah, they're the exception because they got together so young.
对，他们是个例外，因为他们在一起时太年轻了。
But if you get together and you have some life under your belt, you also have some history and you have some incredible memories and vacations and mementos and things that are going to you, they've probably taken their kind of rightful place in your, you know, credenza of memories and they're not like actively provoking you and maybe you like that throw pillow or whatever, but to the newish boyfriend or girlfriend, they can be very provocative because it feels like, well, you're holding on to a piece of them, you haven't let that go.
但如果你是在有了一定人生阅历之后才在一起，你也会有一些过去，有一些美好的回忆、假期、纪念品以及各种东西，它们可能会在你的记忆五斗橱里占据它们应有的位置，平时并不会主动刺激你，也许你还挺喜欢那个抱枕什么的。但对于新交往的男友或女友来说，这些东西可能会极具挑衅性，因为这感觉就像是，你在保留他们的一部分，你还没放下。
Like, how significant was this for you if you still have these pieces and mementos around the apartment.
就像是，如果你公寓里还留着这些物件和纪念品，这说明这段过去对你有多重要。
Yeah, and it's part of your life story before you met that person, but it's also fair for that person to be a little bit weary of it, maybe.
是的，这是你遇到那个人之前的人生故事的一部分，但对于那个人来说，对此感到有些戒备或许也是情有可原的。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, I don't know.
对，我不知道。
I think it's a good philosophical debate.
我觉得这是一场很好的哲学辩论。
I don't know that there's a right or wrong answer to it, but it's like, it's very human.
我不知道这有没有对错之分，但这真的很人性化。
I think everybody, even Marshall and Lily, there's Marshall's earlier in this season was really triggered at the idea that scooter had gotten a little bit further around the bases with Lilly, than he thought.
我觉得每个人，甚至连马修和莉莉也是，马修在这季早些时候就因为斯库特跟莉莉的发展比他想象的要稍微深入了一点而感到非常破防。
Even in that situation, it's like, they've basically only been with each other, but there's still that, and I think it's just, it's very real, it's very real.
即使在这种情况下，他们基本上只和彼此在一起过，但依然会有那种情绪，我觉得这真的很真实，非常真实。
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City.
我为你写了这首在纽约市送给你的小歌。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈尔德曼，《Hyper-Fixed》播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会接听听众的问题并试着帮他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的问题：我30岁了，在纽约开车感到很害怕。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时不能调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你遇到了问题，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭示导致该问题背后的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at hyperfixedpod.com.
您可以在各大播客平台或访问 hyperfixedpod.com 收听。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目中。
There's a kind of, I don't know, there's a kind of like greed component to love.
爱情里好像有一种，我不知道，有一种类似贪婪的成分。
Like I wanna be the only one you've ever felt this way about.
就像我想成为你唯一一个有过这种感觉的人。
I wanna be the only one, you know?
我想成为唯一的一个，你知道吗？
I will say that the recurring visual bit that I thought Pam and the team did such a great job with is like the objects and Ted's apartment turning into these women who then taught Robin and then the dogs turning into these ex-boyfriends.
我要说的是，我觉得帕姆和团队在视觉上做得很棒的一个反复出现的桥段，就是泰德公寓里的物品变成了这些女人，然后她们教导罗宾，还有狗狗变成了这些前男友。
It did, that was one of the things where I was like, You cannot do that at a live taping in one night like that is like that's proper filmmaking.
确实，有一件事让我觉得，你不可能在一晚上的现场录制中做到这一点，这简直是真正的电影制作。
It reminded me like when when the objects were morphing into the women that did it dated Jordan and I like we're always struggling like what movies or TV shows to watch because our taste somewhat overlap sometimes but also often veer.
这让我想起，当那些物品变形为约旦约会过的女性时，我和乔丹娜总是为看什么电影或电视剧而苦恼，因为我们的品味有时会有所交集，但往往也会分歧。
But for some reason the other night, we watched it over two nights and I had never seen it and I just want to say I enjoyed every frame of it.
但不知为什么前几天晚上，我们分两晚看完了它，我从没看过，我只想说我享受它的每一个画面。
We watched Terminator 2.
我们看了《终结者2》。
Oh fuck yeah.
哦，操，太棒了。
Wait, had you never seen Terminator 2?
等等，你以前没看过《终结者2》吗？
Terminator 2, don't you guys don't yell at me.
《终结者2》，你们别，别对我大喊大叫。
I'm saying I was watching it.
我是说我当时在看。
It's one of Jordana's favorite movies.
这是乔丹娜最喜欢的电影之一。
She said her name.
她说了她的名字。
Jordana, yes Jordana.
乔丹娜，对，乔丹娜。
It's one of my favorite movies.
这是我最喜欢的电影之一。
Yeah, I love that movie.
对，我很喜欢那部电影。
I was watching it.
我当时在看。
And first of all, I want to say I was watching it.
首先，我想说我当时在看。
and I was like, is James Cameron actually maybe the best director frame for frame of like, the action sequences that are so, it's unbelievable that movie that like got made in what 92 or something, like, 91?
我当时想，詹姆斯·卡梅隆其实会不会真的是那种动作场面逐帧来看最棒的导演？那些动作场面太棒了，这部电影竟然是在92年还是什么的时候拍出来的，这简直难以置信，是91年吗？
Yeah, I think 92, 91, 91, but I referenced it in my novel, Josh, I don't know if you remember, there's a moment where Rob and my novel is having a hard day and his wife Paige comes home and finds him watching Terminator 2 because she says that's his, that's his movie.
对，我想是92年，91年，91年，不过我在我的小说里提到过它，乔希，我不知道你记不记得，有一个情节是罗布在我的小说里正经历艰难的一天，他的妻子佩姬回家发现他在看《终结者2》，因为她说那是他的电影。
He watches when he's having a hard day because men think that when they're having a bad day, the stakes are the apocalypse, like that's how male brains work.
他过得不顺心时就会看这个，因为男人以为他们遇到倒霉事时，面临的赌注就是世界末日，男人的大脑就是这样运作的。
So they need to watch an apocalypse to help them feel.
所以他们需要看一场世界末日来帮助自己感受情绪。
But I really, and that's what I really do.
但我真的，这正是我一直在做的。
I really watch a movie all the time.
我确实一直在看电影。
It feels as good as any, you could stack that movie up against any classic Hollywood classic.
它感觉好极了，你可以把这部电影跟任何好莱坞经典电影相提并论。
And it's like frame for frame, it is, I was never bored.
而且可以说是逐帧来看，它确实如此，我从来没有感到无聊。
It's like a fully explored and executed universe.
这就像是一个被充分探索和呈现的宇宙。
I really thought it was like a masterpiece.
我真的觉得它就像是一部杰作。
It's like a perfect piece of writing, too.
它也像是一部完美的文学作品。
It's perfectly constructed that story, but what it reminded me of, the way that the pillow morphs into a woman reminded me of the liquid metal, the guy, the scarier robot, I so forgot what we were talking about, but I thought we all had a gummy right at the beginning.
那个故事结构完美，但它让我想起的是，枕头变成女人的那种方式让我想起了液态金属，那个家伙，那个更可怕的机器人，我太忘了我们刚才在说什么了，但我以为我们一开始都吃了一颗软糖。
No, we're doing a podcast about terminators here.
不，我们这里在做一期关于终结者的播客。
Are we recording this?
我们在录音吗？
It's our relaunch podcast of terminator, we do it, but it reminded me of the liquid metal, how he could just reconstitute himself.
这是我们关于《终结者》的重启播客，我们做了，但它让我想起了液态金属，他是如何重塑自己的。
I bet we gave that as a mnemonic to the effect house.
我敢说我们当时把这个作为提示给特效公司了。
We said we wanted to be Terminator 2.
我们说过我们想要达到《终结者2》的效果。
It allowed us to at least do a tight 90 seconds on the glories of Terminator 2.
这让我们至少能用短短90秒来赞美《终结者2》的辉煌。
It's so good.
它太棒了。
Yeah, I'm so glad I know it now, and my dad too is also like, yeah, it's one of the best movies.
是的，我很高兴我现在知道了，我爸爸也觉得，是的，这是最好的电影之一。
It's also like the rare Godfather 2, an amazingly good sequel that's maybe as good or better than the first one.
它也像罕见的《教父2》一样，是一部极其出色的续集，可能和第一部一样好，甚至比第一部更好。
It just doesn't happen that up.
这种情况实在太少见了。
But we were trying, both of them were on Netflix and we were trying to decide if we watched Terminator 1 or Terminator 2 and she says, we'll watch the preview for Terminator 1.
但我们当时在试，两部都在Netflix上，我们在纠结是看《终结者1》还是《终结者2》，然后她说，我们看一下《终结者1》的预告片吧。
I watched the preview and I was like, okay, I understand what happened in Terminator 1.
我看过预告片后觉得，好吧，我明白《终结者1》里发生了什么。
It's also great.
它也很棒。
It's also great and worth going back, but Terminator 2 is probably better.
它同样很棒，值得重温，但《终结者2》可能更好。
I know it's great, but I'm also like, I'm ready now to watch Terminator 2.
我知道它很棒，但我也觉得，我已经准备好看《终结者2》了。
Yeah, Terminator 2 is better.
对，2号终结者更好。
So you have maybe made the right call.
所以你可能做出了正确的决定。
Yeah.
对。
Oh, it's amazing.
哦，太棒了。
But yes, that effect is very liquidy.
不过是的，那个特效非常具有液体感。
the way in those, they sort of like the little British phone was sort of a liquid lease expands into this human.
就像那些画面里，那个类似小英国电话亭的东西变成了一种液态，然后扩展成了人形。
Yeah, I like that effect.
对，我很喜欢那个特效。
It's very similar.
非常相似。
And that was the other kind of great effect and we can talk later about this, but the sped up argument between Robin and Ted at the end that ends in them somehow limping their way across the finish line with the revelation that they should move in together.
那是另一种很棒的特效，我们待会儿可以讨论这个，不过罗宾和泰德在结尾那段语速加快的争吵，最终以某种方式跌跌撞撞地冲过终点线，并透露出他们应该同居的消息。
It is not our first fast forwarded argument in series.
这并不是我们剧集里第一次出现快进的争吵。
in season two, we've maybe had four or five of them.
在第二季里，我们大概有过四五次这样的桥段。
We love that device.
我们很喜欢这种手法。
You can't do that.
你不能那样做。
It's a good bit.
这是一个很好的包袱。
It's a live audience.
这是现场观众。
Yeah.
对。
And by the way, I was trying to remember, I think you and Carter or Courtney wrote us some dialogue, or did you just say fight?
顺便说一句，我在努力回想，我想你和卡特或者考特尼为我们写了一些台词，还是说你们只是让我自由发挥？
Do you remember?
你还记得吗？
I think we wrote, I think Courtney probably wrote up a map of like, let's cover these bases and so it's to help it last long enough, but I bet you guys improved around whatever a little map was.
我想我们写过，我觉得考特尼可能写了一份大纲，比如“我们要覆盖这些要点”，好让这场戏能持续足够长的时间，但我敢打赌，你们俩一定根据那个小大纲即兴发挥了。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
It'd be fun to ask Kobe if she remembers, but I think we did have, I think at that point, we knew the terrain of both our relationship and the central argument that we probably just got unleashed.
问问寇碧她是否还记得会很有趣，但我想我们确实有，我觉得在那时，我们已经很清楚彼此的关系以及核心争论的框架，所以我们可能就直接放飞自我了。
And I think my memory is we were going crazy, we were doing it and she was, Pam was kind of sending us around the room so she could get a variety of things.
我的记忆是，我们当时快疯了，我们在演这段时，帕姆一直在现场引导我们换不同的角度，这样她就能剪辑出丰富多样的画面。
I wonder how long you did it for, how long it was.
我很好奇你们拍了多久，这场戏到底有多长。
But I do, I think I remember at the end, Pam called Cut and I think the crew applauded.
但我记得在最后，帕姆喊了停，然后我记得剧组鼓掌了。
Like I think the crew was like into it.
我觉得剧组当时完全被带入戏了。
Like it was a Eugene O'Neill.
就像在看尤金·奥尼尔的戏剧一样。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, like we really, but we really, even in the fast forward, you can see that we were in it.
对，对，对，对，就像我们真的，即便在快进中，你也能看出我们完全投入其中。
We were really.
我们真的很投入。
You were having a fight and it was so well done that the twist that they make this decision to move in together plays like a great surprise because like how the fuck did we get there?
你们当时在吵架，而且演得太棒了，以至于他们决定同居这个大反转就像是一个巨大的惊喜，因为大家会想：我们他妈的到底是怎么走到这一步的？
It's great, I almost forgot.
太棒了，我都快忘了。
And that is the sort of like emotional ballast of this episode.
这就是这一集的情感支柱。
Something important happens at the end of this episode that sets up a whole new condition that we explore for the rest of season two.
这一集的结尾发生了一件重要的事情，为我们接下来在整个第二季中探讨的全新状况做好了铺垫。
So that you need that at the end of this episode.
所以你在这一集的结尾需要这个。
What strikes me as we're talking that the A story between Ted and Robin is what do you owe your partner vis-a-vis your past?
在我们谈论时，让我印象深刻的是，泰德和罗宾之间的A线讲的是：对于过去，你对伴侣负有什么责任？
Yes.
是的。
And the B story is actually about friendship.
而B线实际上是关于友谊的。
What do you owe your friends?
你对朋友负有什么责任？
Yeah, I like that.
对，我喜欢这个。
When they ask you to kind of sit through something somewhat unbearable.
当他们要求你忍受某些相当难以忍受的事情时。
To me that makes this a more structurally sound episode than like columns.
在我看来，这使得这一集在结构上比那些“互不相干的故事线”更加扎实。
Remember we were talking about that with some columns a few episodes earlier where it was like the A story and the B story were very separate and they didn't really dove to You could have dropped the B story into any other episode.
还记得我们在前面几集里讨论过某些故事线吗？当时A线和B线完全是分开的，它们根本没有交集，你完全可以把B线塞进任何其他一集里。
And that is not us playing or at strength.
那并不是我们发挥最佳水准的表现。
You see us still, we're still learning in season two.
你看，在第二季里我们仍在学习。
What are our superpowers?
我们的超能力是什么？
What are our things that are harder?
我们有哪些方面觉得更难驾驭？
Separate A, B story is not good on how much mother.
A、B线完全分离并不适合《老爸老妈的浪漫史》。
This flirts with being that, but the emotional kind of overlap of what do you owe partner?
这一集有点接近那种模式，但“你对伴侣负有什么责任？”和“你对朋友负有什么责任？”这两者在情感上产生了重叠。
What do you owe a friend?
你对朋友负有什么责任？
The whole episode is this kind of philosophical symposium based on what do you owe these people you love.
整集节目就像是一场基于“你对你爱的人负有什么责任”的哲学研讨会。
And also the honesty versus the kind of obfuscation piece.
还有诚实与某种模棱两可、遮遮掩掩之间的较量。
Do I act like I've never once dated anybody else?
我要表现得好像我从来没和别人约会过吗？
Do I act like my friends play as great, even when it's totally horrible to sit through?
我要装作我的朋友们讲的笑话很棒吗，即使听起来完全是一种折磨？
What do we owe each other honesty and transparency?
我们彼此之间亏欠的是诚实与透明吗？
Or do we owe each other lies and glazing things over?
还是说我们彼此亏欠的是谎言和粉饰太平？
I don't know.
我不知道。
There's a very famous couple's therapist named Terry Reel, Terence Reel, and he writes great books.
有一个非常著名的夫妻治疗师叫特里·雷尔（Terry Reel），也就是特伦斯·雷尔（Terence Reel），他写过很多优秀的图书。
But yeah, I've heard him say this a number of times interviews, that one of the worst things you can engage in in a partnership is what he calls unbridled self-expression.
但对，我听他在采访中多次说过，在伴侣关系中最糟糕的事情之一就是他所谓的“无节制的自我表达”。
Like just saying, like, I'm just being honest, but you're also being cruel.
就像只是说：“我只是在实话实说”，但你其实也很残忍。
You're using no discernment, you're using no softening of tone, you're in total opposition, and you're just trying to take them out at the kneecaps.
你没有丝毫的分寸感，没有缓和语气的意识，你完全站在对立面，只是想在对方的软肋上给致命一击。
There's no, it's like fighting unfairly.
这完全没有，这就好像在进行不公平的争吵。
Right?
对吧？
Yeah.
对。
And Barney, at least from a friend perspective, is a fan of unbridled self-expression.
而巴尼，至少从朋友的角度来看，他是无节制自我表达的粉丝。
Radical honesty, radical self-expression.
激进的诚实，激进的自我表达。
Like I have to say, this is- But he can't handle it back to him, but he wants to be able to dole it out.
就像我必须说，这是——但他自己却承受不起别人这样对付他，但他却很乐意去批判别人。
That's the other thing.
这就是另一回事了。
That's off in the case.
情况往往如此。
情况往往就是这样。
That is off in the case.
情况确实如此。
Yeah.
对。
Whereas I think Ted is trying not to do- Ted gets pushed in points and he does engage in that.
然而我认为泰德正努力避免这样做——泰德在某些节点上被逼急了，他确实也会那样做。
Like there's a bunch of moments you could map out in the series where Ted like- can't take it anymore.
比如你可以在剧中列举出一堆这样的时刻，泰德在那些时刻——再也忍受不下去了。
And he finally says the thing he shouldn't have said.
他最终说出了他不该说的话。
You know, and it's like, oh, fudge.
你知道，这就像是，哦，糟糕。
Like, you know, there's these moments, right?
你知道，会有这些时刻，对吧？
But I think like, even at the beginning when he tries to be like, oh, no, that was with my sister.
但我认为，甚至在一开始当他试图掩饰说“哦，不，那是跟我姐姐在一起”时。
Like he's really trying to protect Robin.
他其实是在拼命保护罗宾。
He's trying to protect.
他在试图保护对方。
Yeah, he knows it's gonna be triggering.
对，他知道这会触及痛点。
That whole sequence of sister is really funny.
关于姐姐的那整段戏真的非常搞笑。
You play in that grade.
你演得太棒了。
It's a good 10 episode.
这是一个很棒的第10集梗。
10 has a lot of funny moments in this one.
这一集里泰德有很多搞笑的时刻。
Well, getting, my favorite was, and we'll talk about this, but getting.
嗯，拿到，我最喜欢的是——我们待会儿会谈到这个——拿到。
Belvedevo.
Belvedevo（老梗）。
No. Old ref though.
不。不过这是个老梗。
Belvedevo is an old ref because Jordana didn't know what that was.
Belvedevo是个老梗，因为乔丹娜根本不知道那是什么意思。
Old tackle.
老笑话。
But Jordana didn't know what Belvedevo is.
但乔丹娜不知道Belvedevo是什么。
We're so old.
我们真的是老了。
But at that joke, you were, you killed that joke.
但那个笑话，你当时，你把那个笑话效果拉满了。
I just want to say that was a great Belvedevo call.
我只想说那是一个非常棒的Belvedevo梗。
Even they don't know what this meant.
甚至他们都不知道这是什么意思。
That was like a laugh out loud.
那个包袱让人忍不住笑出声来。
I watched it twice that loud.
我大声笑了出来，还看了两遍。
I went back to watch it loud twice.
我倒回去大声笑了两次。
While we're here, while we're here, why don't we just talk about that moment?
既然我们在这儿，既然我们在这儿，为什么我们不直接聊聊那个时刻呢？
Okay, Jay, that is a- Butterfuca.
好的，杰，那是一个——Butterfuca。
The Butterfuca pants that Marshall parades in.
马歇尔招摇过市穿着的那条Butterfuca裤子。
And another, it's Oracle of Delphi.
还有一个，就是德尔斐的先知。
They're trying to get- It's another one of them.
他们试图弄——这也是其中之一。
They're trying to- It's the thing.
他们试图——就是那个东西。
They're like, we have to put it to the group and take it to the group.
他们就觉得，我们必须把它提交给集体，带去由集体决定。
There's something about, there's five of them.
好像是，一共有五个成员。
So there's always a tiebreaker.
所以总能打破平局。
Like there's a, you know, it's a good number for that, for the high model.
就好像是一个，你知道，对于那个大模型来说，这是个很好的数字。
Yeah, they're a conveniently odd number, yeah.
对，它们是一个很凑巧的奇数，对。
Marshall is doing one thing.
马歇尔在做一件事。
But Jason Segal, when we shot that, I remember it was like he walked out, and I think we rehearsed it obviously without the pants because we weren't in costume yet.
但杰森·席格尔，当我们拍那一幕时，我记得他走出来，我记得我们显然排练过，没穿那条裤子，因为我们还没换上戏服。
But he walked out and I just, I will never forget, Jason Siegel walking out and kind of, he was like clucking his head like a chicken, like kind of his chin was going back and forth and he kept going, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh.
但他走出来，我真的——我永远不会忘记杰森·席格尔走出来的那种样子，他像鸡一样点着头，下巴来回晃动，嘴里一直念叨着，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃。
And he knew that we were dying.
而且他知道我们快笑死了。
He knew that we were dying, even Neil was dying Neil was the least breaky of all of us.
他知道我们快笑死了，连尼尔都快笑死了，尼尔可是我们当中最不容易笑场的人。
Me, Ali, and Kobe were gone, like gone, gone, gone.
我和阿莉、寇碧早就笑崩了，彻底崩了，完全崩了。
And I was shocked at how quick the pop was and how we looked like you couldn't, like Sue Fetterman and Pam must have, you guys must have had a search for a serious face.
让我震惊的是，大家破功得这么快，我们当时的样子简直——你们一定——苏·费特曼和帕姆，你们当时肯定费了好大劲才憋住严肃的表情。
I bet we found the frames you weren't breaking.
我敢说，我们找到了你们没笑场的那些镜头。
We found the five frames you weren't breaking.
我们找到了你们没有笑场的五个镜头。
It was one of those where Pam had to be like, guys, professional acting, please, please, Because he would, and you know, when Siegel or Neil knew that they were making you laugh, it wasn't like they were trying to help you get through the scene.
当时那种情况，帕姆不得不说：“伙计们，拿出点专业演员的样子来，拜托，拜托。”因为他会——你知道的，当席格尔或尼尔知道他们在逗你笑时，他们可不是在帮你能顺利拍完这场戏。
They were trying to crush you, they wanted you to, and the way that Jason paraded these pants around, and he, and he, when he knew that we were losing it, he just amped it up to 11, you know, it was just like, it made me laugh so much.
他们是想把你彻底击溃，他们就想让你笑，而且杰森穿着这条裤子招摇过市的那种架势，当他知道我们快要失控时，他直接把恶搞程度开到了11级，你知道的，真的太好笑了。
I watched that whole scene over twice and he was when he was like, when he was going like Ted.
我把整场戏看了两遍，当他那样说的时候——当他说“泰德”的时候。
Ted.
泰德。
He's like, he's like, come on.
他就像是，他就像是，得了吧。
You got me.
你把我逗乐了。
You got that back here.
你把那个又带回来了。
And even Ted can't go.
甚至连泰德都绷不住了。
Oh my God.
哦天哪。
But I'm telling you, we probably we had to do like eight takes of this very quick.
但我告诉你们，我们大概——我们得拍个八条才能把这一小段非常快地拍完。
But normally that should have been three takes tops.
但正常情况下，顶多三条就该过了。
Yeah.
对。
It was just such a one off little thing.
那真是一个极其独特的搞笑小插曲。
But I remember that as one of the other one was, I remember because I was trying to get to burning man, you guys were trying to get me out so I could go burning man.
但我记得那是一次，还有另一次我记得是因为我当时正赶着去火人节，你们当时在想方设法把我弄走好让我去火人节。
I think second or third season.
我想是第二季还是第三季。
But what was the one where Lily walks in, oh, it was the intervention episode, where she walks in with a Cockney accent.
但莉莉走进来的是哪一集来着，哦，就是干预那一集，她顶着一口伦敦腔走进来。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对，对。
And we had never rehearsed it.
而且我们从没排练过。
We just did it, because I think maybe it was a rewrite that it was a Cockney accent.
我们直接就拍了，因为我觉得可能是临时改剧本加了伦敦腔。
And Ally walks in with that Cockney accent, and we lost our minds.
然后阿莉顶着那个伦敦腔走进来，我们直接心态崩了。
Lost your shit.
彻底笑喷了。
And I was like, this is the funniest thing I've ever seen, and I have to catch a plane.
我当时就想：这是我见过最好笑的事，可我还得去赶飞机。
Like, I have to go.
就像是，我必须得走了。
I am fucking myself over by laughing this lecture.
我因为在这儿狂笑简直是在自毁前程。
So there are a couple moments when you, I mean, I think people like hearing about this moments where we just lost our minds on set laughing.
所以有那么几个瞬间，我是说，我觉得人们喜欢听这种我们在片场笑到失控的故事。
Yeah, it's not like that was happening all the time.
对，这可不是经常发生的事。
It had to be something truly out of the ordinary, like the Buttafooko pants.
那一定是非常不寻常的事情，比如那条“Buttafooko”裤子。
And by the way, that must have been old ref too.
顺便说一句，那肯定也是个老梗了。
I'm sure I don't know, Jordana, did she?
我敢说——我不知道，乔丹娜，她知道吗？
Did you recognize them?
你认出来了吗？
Buttafooko was like, that is a deep cut 1990s, like embarrassing Long Island story.
“Buttafooko”那种感觉就像是一个超级冷门的90年代长岛尴尬故事。
But if you lived through the 90s, it's no explanation needed.
但如果你经历过90年代，那就完全不需要解释。
Yeah.
对。
It was in Coby's thing of like, I don't want you to get shot in the face, right?
这就跟寇碧说的“我可不想你的脸被枪打中”一样，对吧？
It was so jarring, it was just right.
太让人猝不及防了，恰到好处。
That's what that story was.
那个故事就是这样的。
Yeah, oh yeah, being from Long Island in the 90s was tough because everyone's like, ah, the butterfly story from Long Island.
对，哦对，90年代在长岛长大可真不容易，因为每个人都会说：“啊，长岛的蝴蝶裤故事。”
Let's talk about that.
我们来聊聊这个吧。
I'm like, no, please, I don't want to represent that.
我就想说：不，求求了，我可不想代表这种形象。
Yeah.
对。
But that was when I watched it, I was like, oh, this is the butterfly pants.
但当我看到那一集时，我就想：哦，这就是那条蝴蝶裤。
Like this is where that was.
这就是出处所在。
And it's a very strong memory of us just being the least professional actor.
这是一段非常深刻的记忆，关于我们当时是多么不专业的演员。
Like we could not keep it together.
就像我们根本没办法克制自己。
And Jason was not helping us at all.
而且杰森一点忙也没帮。
This was a weird week.
那真是古怪的一周。
Cause you had that and then you had guys licking your face.
因为你先是遇到了那个，然后又碰上别人舔你的脸。
Yeah.
对。
There's a lot of weird stuff.
有好多奇奇怪怪的事情。
Neil's dressed in a 10 man robot outfit and saying the word moist over and over again.
尼尔穿着一身10英尺高的机器人服装，嘴里反复念叨着“湿润”这个词。
It was a weird, it was a genuinely like fever dream of an episode in some ways.
那真是一个古怪的、从某种程度上来说宛如发烧做梦般的剧集。
Yeah.
对。
Do you know what my biggest laugh was actually?
你知道我笑得最厉害的是什么吗？
What?
什么？
Jordana pointed it out or I would have missed it.
是乔丹娜指出来的，不然我都错过了。
You never say it.
你从来不说这个。
but it's just over the corner of the pro, the name of the play.
但它就在道具的角落里，那是那个戏剧的名字。
Suck it, Lily, suck it, Lily.
《滚你的吧，莉莉》，《滚你的吧，莉莉》。
That he, I was called Suck it, Lily.
那个，我当时那部剧叫《滚你的吧，莉莉》。
Me too, I lost my mind at that.
我也是，我看到那个直接笑疯了。
I had completely forgotten about it.
我完全把这事忘得精光。
Like to the point where I was like, did I not, did props do that without us asking them to?
甚至到了这种程度：我在想，难道不是——难道是道具组在我们不知情的情况下自己加上去的吗？
And I never noticed it.
而我居然从来没注意到。
It was so funny to me, and also I had a genuine question.
我觉得太好笑了，而且我当时有一个真诚的疑问。
So funny.
太搞笑了。
Who are the other people coming to see this play?
到底是谁在来看这部剧的其他观众？
I said the same thing, Drew Becca, I was like, how, especially Neil's play.
我也这么说，德鲁·贝卡，我当时就在想，怎么会，尤其是尼尔的剧。
No, that's what I meant, Neil's play.
不，我是那个意思，尼尔的剧。
I could understand friends and family come to the other play, but who is coming to see Suck It Lily by Barney Stinson?
我还能理解朋友和家人会来看另一部剧，但谁会来看巴尼·斯廷森创作的《滚你的吧，莉莉》？
And then walking out, as if like, this isn't as great as I expected it to be.
然后他们还一副若有所思走出去的样子，好像在说“这没有我想象的那么棒”。
The times review wildly inflated how good this was.
《泰晤士报》的评论把这玩意儿夸得天花乱坠。
I said the same, like, who are these people?
我也这么说，就觉得：这群人到底是谁？
Oh my God.
哦天哪。
And also, it was the same venue and the same.
而且，这还是在同一个场地。
the same exact venue, the same crew, who was on our crew.
完全相同的场地，同样的剧组人员，就是我们的剧组人员。
It was on our crew.
就是我们的剧组。
Yeah, that was the second Lily thing.
对，那是关于莉莉的第二件事。
I was like, that was just where it's called though for me.
我当时就觉得，对我来说这才是真正的笑点。
I was like, whoa, I completely forgot about that play.
我当时想：哇，我把那出戏忘得一干二净。
Such a funny, like, if you catch that, it's so funny.
太好笑了，如果你注意到了，真的会笑死。
Ooh, really good, really funny.
哦，太棒了，太搞笑了。
But I almost felt like, did I never notice that, which is insane to say.
但我甚至觉得：我以前真的从来没注意到过吗？说出来简直难以置信。
But that's how much I forgot that.
但我完全忘了这一点。
Well, I think you had to have because the way Pam shot it, it was like.
嗯，我想你肯定记得，因为帕姆拍摄它的方式，感觉就像。
We probably wrote it.
我们可能写过它。
But it could like the way the person was arching and holding up the program was clearly so you could see it It's almost like a Simpsons joke.
但它可能——那个人弯腰举着节目的姿势，显然是为了让你看清楚，这简直就像一个《辛普森一家》的笑梗。
It was such a quick visual throw a plan or something.
这是一个非常快速的视觉梗，比如一张飞机票什么的。
Yeah, or an airplane exactly And I love that you didn't hit like you didn't we never called it out We never called out that that was the show's but also like Lily was probably handed a program That said suck it Lily and she just like moves on with it Yeah, it's something great up There was something great about not calling it out at all, and it's just there for you to find.
对，或者一张飞机票，完全是这样。而且我喜欢你没有点破——就像你没有，我们从来没有挑明过那是剧组的……但同时，莉莉可能拿到了一份节目单，上面写着“去你的吧，莉莉”，而她就这么顺理成章地继续演下去了。没错，不点破任何东西真的很棒，它就静静地在那里，等着你去发现。
And it's the same thing as the slap bed at the end.
这跟最后的“耳光之床”是一样的道理。
It's like, it's there, even if you have no idea what the slap bed even is, it's you're like, all right, well, he just wanted to slap the shit out of him.
就像它就在那里，即使你完全不知道什么是“耳光之床”，你也会想，好吧，反正他就是想狠狠地扇巴掌。
That's two wouldn't make any sense, but the slapping the shit out of Barney made enough sense.
两样东西连起来可能说不通，但狠狠地扇巴掌给巴尼足够说不通。
There's something nice about the under explanation, something like that.
适度留白、点到为止，这种感觉真的很棒。
There's something nice about just leave it, let it speak for itself.
有些东西就留在那里，让它不言自明，这种感觉很好。
Yeah, you know what really made me laugh?
是啊，你知道什么真的让我笑出来吗？
And I loved playing it, was like in Lily's play how Ted gets roped in to being, was he capitalism?
而且我很喜欢演那场戏，就像在莉莉的话剧里，泰德怎么就被拉进去了，他当时演的是资本主义吗？
What was he greed, capitalism?
他演的是贪婪，还是资本主义？
He was capitalism, I think, or maybe he's creepfucker.
我想他演的是资本主义，或者也许他是那个恶心混蛋。
But I love what Marshall says.
但我很喜欢马歇尔说的台词。
Oh my God, tits in this place.
天哪，这里好多奶子。
Yeah, he's so excited.
对，他太兴奋了。
And then he's really jealous later.
然后他过一会儿又觉得很嫉妒。
I never get chosen to be in this.
我从来没被选上参演这玩意儿。
And it's funny because it's almost like a small payoff.
这很有趣，因为这就像是一个小小的彩蛋回馈。
And we didn't, again, we didn't call it out.
而且我们，再说一次，我们没有点破它。
Maybe it would have been nice call it out.
也许点破它也会挺好的。
At the very end, Marshall is part of the show.
在最后，马歇尔成了演出的一部分。
He's part of the show.
他是演出的一部分。
When he slaps the shit out of the party, he's part of that show.
当他狠狠地扇了巴尼一巴掌时，他就是那场演出的一部分。
He's the day of sex.
他是天外神掌。
He's in his head.
他在他脑子里。
He's the day of sex slopina.
他是天外神掌斯洛皮娜。
Is the day is like slapping a see when shit like that comes up.
天外神掌就像是扇了一个——瞧，当这种事出现的时候。
It's like when Elliot coin the phrase, Tegendary, I just want to get in a time machine.
就像埃利奥特创造了“传奇”这个词一样，我真想坐进时间机器里。
I want Deus Ex slapping out to be on the show.
我真想让“天外神掌”出现在剧集里。
I guess this is the next best thing when these things come up on the podcast, but it does break my heart a little bit because Deus Ex slapping a is fucking brilliant job.
我想当这些事情在播客里被提出来时，这已经是次优选择了，但它还是让我有点心碎，因为“天外神掌”真的是个该死的天才创意。
Thank you.
谢谢。
And now, you know, there's also one of my greatest fears is being roped into audience participation while I'm like at a player concert.
现在，你知道的，我最大的恐惧之一就是在看话剧或音乐会时，被拉进观众互动环节。
I want zero eyes on me if I'm in the audience.
如果我坐在观众席里，我希望全场零双眼睛看着我。
Okay, well, question for you, let's do the symposium.
好吧，有个问题想问你，我们来做个专题讨论吧。
You're a wonderful actor.
你是个出色的演员。
You're a wonderful theater actor.
你是个出色的戏剧演员。
Thank you.
谢谢。
And a sidebar, if anybody out here has the chance to see Josh on stage live a fantastic and different theater actor than you are TV.
顺便说一句，如果这里有人有机会去现场看乔什的演出，他是一个非常棒、与你在电视上完全不同的戏剧演员。
Like you really, there's different superpowers you on both.
真的，你在两者身上展现出了不同的超能力。
Okay, as you've gotten to plenty of shows, sometimes they're terrible.
好了，既然你看过很多演出，有时它们真的很烂。
What do you say to the friend in the show?
你对演出的朋友会说什么？
Are you ever, are you ever flirting with that honesty level?
你曾经试探过那种诚实的底线吗？
Or you were great, but the show sucked.
还是说“你演得很棒，但剧太烂了”？
You ever tried to like, shoot, like, parse it out?
你有没有试过像这样去剖析它？
My friend, Dion Flynn, who's like, he's a writer for The Tonight Show, and he is one of my dearest friends.
我的朋友迪恩·弗林，他是《今夜秀》的编剧，也是我最亲爱的朋友之一。
We have a two decade old running bit, 25 year running bit, about what you say to a friend who's show you hated when you go back to.
我们有一个延续了二十年的老梗，一个25年的老梗，关于当你去看一个你讨厌的朋友的演出时，你会对他说什么。
Well, that's, here we are, we're in this episode.
好吧，这就是我们现在聊到的这个。
One of his lines is, you were never better, which is like really confusing.
他的金句之一是：“你从未有过如此出色的状态，”这听起来真的很让人困惑。
Yeah, I feel like it'd be a zer.
对，我觉得这算是个回旋镖。
You know, you were up there, man.
你知道的，“你当时就在台上，老兄。”
Like, I forget he has so many good ones.
天哪，我忘了他说过的好梗太多了。
He's actually compiled the list of all of ours.
他甚至把我们所有人的这些话都整理成了一个列表。
But it is, I think it's a bit of like actors who a lot of times, especially when you're younger, the audience is mostly actors, they're your friends, who are coming to see your show.
但这确实，我觉得这有点像演员——很多时候，特别是当你年轻的时候，观众大多是演员，他们是你的朋友，来看你的演出。
So you have to kind of like, sometimes you're bold away.
所以你有时不得不，有时你会惊叹不已。
Like, I remember going to see Chris Messina in a show.
就像我记得去Flea剧院看克里斯·墨西拿演出的情景。
he invited me to a show that he was in off-Broadway with at the flea.
他邀请我去看他在外百老汇参演的一部戏。
I remember that play.
我还记得那出戏。
I just, I was like Chris, this is, like it was one of those performances I was like, I couldn't give that performance.
我当时就对克里斯说，这——那是一场让我觉得“我绝对演不出那种效果”的表演。
It was so daring and scary and incredible, incredible.
它是那么的大胆、惊悚又不可思议，简直不可思议。
But yeah, it's a lot of actors who are, do you know the joke of how many actors does it take to screw in a light bulb?
但话又说回来，很多演员——你知道那个笑话吗：换一个灯泡需要多少个演员？
How many?
多少个？
100, one to screw in the light bulb, 99 to sit in the audience with complimentary tickets and say how they could have done it better.
100个，一个负责拧灯泡，另外99个拿着免费赠票坐在观众席里，评头论足地说他们自己本来可以演得更好。
That's it.
就是这样。
I mean, it's, my wife is a dancer, choreographer.
我是说，我妻子是个舞蹈演员兼编舞。
So we've gone and seen a lot of like very funky, very downtown, tiny little performances.
所以我们看过很多非常前卫的、非常市中心的、极其微小的表演。
And sometimes they're genuinely not that far off from Barney and the Robot costume or Lily's thing.
有时它们真的跟巴尼的机器人服装或莉莉的节目没差多少。
They're sometimes super crazy and we can go be, we can be celebrate, we can be there to support a certain performer and think they were amazing.
它们有时疯狂至极，我们可以去成为——我们可以去庆祝，我们可以去支持某个特定的表演者，并认为他们真的很棒。
They moved their movement was amazing.
他们的肢体语言太棒了。
They were great, but the show as a whole was didn't grab us, we didn't like the show, but we thought they were great.
他们很棒，但整部剧作为一个整体并没有吸引我们，我们不喜欢这部剧，但我们觉得他们很棒。
But even that, when you try to drive, you almost can't say that either, because somebody coming off stage doesn't want to hear about how the show sucked, but they were great, because maybe they needed to believe the show was great, to give that amazing performance.
但即便如此，当你想去表达时，你几乎也没法把这话宣之于口，因为一个刚下台的人并不想听关于“这出戏太烂了，但你演得很好”的评价，因为他们可能需要相信这部戏本身很棒，才能奉献出那种惊艳的表演。
It's just weirding, because you want to believe you were part of something, and all your efforts was, well, it came to something, and that people had a good experience.
这真的很微妙，因为你希望相信自己是某个伟大作品的一部分，你所有的努力都有所回报，而且人们都有过一段美妙的体验。
One of the worst things you can say to an actor after a play, and this is just a public service announcement, congratulations is a terrible thing to say.
在看完一场戏后，你能对一个演员说的最糟糕的话之一——这算是一则公益公告——就是“祝贺你”。
You know they hated it when they say that.
你知道当他们说出这句话时，他们其实恨透了这场戏。
Yeah, when they say congratulations, it's like, they're not, this was not something they.
对，当他们说“祝贺你”的时候，这就好像……这根本不是一件值得他们……
Yeah, you were in that.
对，你确实参演了。
You were in that.
你确实在里面。
You were up there.
你就在那个舞台上。
That existed and you were there.
那东西确实存在过，而你也确实经历过。
I believe when you were on stage, I believed you were there.
我相信当你在舞台上时，我相信你就身处其中。
Um, yeah, um, I will say years ago, a college friend of mine, Beth Schachter, we were at a play.
嗯，对，我得说多年前，我大学的一个朋友，贝丝·沙克特，我们一起去看了一场戏。
It was like an evening of one acts that were, um, it was all absurdist.
那是一个独幕剧之夜，全是荒诞派风格的。
It was kind of like, it was, it was like tin foil, Nanae's cover, you know, people.
有点像是锡纸做的纳奈服装那种感觉，你知道的。
It was very strange.
那真是非常奇怪。
And my friend, who I went to college with, she directed me a lot in plays in college.
我的这位大学同学，在大学里曾多次执导过我的话剧。
She leaned over to me in the middle of it.
她在演出中途朝我靠过来。
And she said, this is the kind of theater our parents fear were making.
她说：“这就是我们的父母最担心我们去创作的那种戏剧。”
That's a great line.
这句台词太棒了。
That's really funny.
真的很好笑。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you.
这个老头，他让我确信，爱上了你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now commercials, end of commercials, back to show.
现在是广告时间，广告结束，回到节目。
It's so hard because when you're in something, it's almost like you can badmouthe your own family.
这太难了，因为当你身处其中时，这就好比你可以说自己家人的不是。
But when somebody else badmouts your family, you're like, wait a second.
但当别人说你家人的不是时，你就会想：等一下。
Like, if I have work on something and somebody goes, I remember even writing for Dave Letterman, which was a great honor.
就像，如果我参与制作了某样东西，然后有人说——我还记得当年为大卫·莱特曼写稿，那是一项极大的荣誉。
I think Dave's a legend.
我觉得大卫是个传奇。
I love Dave.
我爱大卫。
Every now and again, I tell someone that and they'd go, oh, I hate him.
每隔一段时间，我跟别人说起这个，他们就会说，噢，我讨厌他。
And I go, well, I don't know what to say to that.
然后我就说，好吧，对此我不知道该说什么。
I write stuff for that show and I love that and I would take it personally that they were dissing Dave, most people love Dave by the way, but it's just weird, it's like I'm not Dave, I didn't create that show, I was just a writer, I was 22 year old writer but I would take it personally and it's like you wanna, it's so hard because you have to believe in the thing you're doing so it's always that dance of like, can I slightly indicate I didn't like the show but I thought the person was amazing in the show and I think it's always, you just can't say it.
我为那个节目写过东西，我很喜欢，而且别人要是贬低戴夫，我会觉得是在针对我——顺便说一句，大多数人都很喜欢戴夫——但这就很奇怪，就好像我不是戴夫，我没有创作那个节目，我只是个编剧，一个22岁的编剧，但我却会把这当成针对我个人的攻击。这真的很纠你懂的，太难了，因为你必须坚信你正在做的事情，所以这里面总有一种拿捏：我能不能稍微暗示一下其实我不太喜欢这个节目，但我认为这个人在这部剧里的表现太棒了？我觉得这总是……你就是没法直说。
And I'm of the feeling that like, especially if someone is a professional or has their eyes set on that.
而且我的感觉是，特别是如果对方是个专业人士，或者一心想要朝这个方向发展的话。
Like, you know, I never would tell someone like, maybe you should consider doing something else.
就像，你知道的，我绝不会对别人说：也许你该考虑干点别的。
Like, that's something, if that comes about, that's gonna be, you know, there's a famous Ed Norton story that he went in and auditioned.
这种事吧，如果真的发生了，那将是……你知道的，有个著名的关于爱德华·诺顿的故事，他以前去试镜。
I'll say who it was, it's George Ann Walken, who was this casting director for years.
我直说是谁吧，是乔治安·沃肯，她做了多年的选角导演。
I don't know if she still does.
我不知道她现在还在不在做。
But I think he was auditioning for the public something he'd been at it for a while.
但我想他当时是在为公共剧院的什么项目试镜，他已经坚持了一段时间了。
And he's told the story many times, but he auditioned and she said, look, I think you're really smart.
他讲过很多次这个故事，他试镜完后，她说，听着，我觉得你真的很聪明。
I like you a lot.
我很喜欢你。
I think you need to start looking at something else to do.
我觉得你需要开始考虑做点别的了。
And like a week later, he booked Primal Fear and he became a movie star and got an Academy where so there's always a thing of like, we don't know what's bad.
结果大约一周后，他接下了《一级恐惧》，成了一名电影明星，还获得过奥斯卡提名，所以世事难料，我们根本不知道什么叫烂。
Nobody knows anything is the rule.
规则就是：谁也不知道什么会火。
And also like, you're an actor, you're an artist, like some things are gonna hit, some things aren't.
而且还有，你是个演员，你是个艺术家，总有些作品会反响热烈，有些则不会。
I think that it's better to keep the enthusiasm up of like, I love you, man, I'm here to support you.
我觉得最好还是保持热情，告诉对方：我爱你，兄弟，我支持你。
I want you to, you know, to do well.
我希望你能，你知道的，发展得很好。
There's a great story.
有个很棒的故事。
I think it was John Krasinski told about that he kind of dissed a movie, either to Paul Thomas Anderson or near Paul Thomas Anderson and Paul Thomas Anderson pulled him aside and he was like, never criticized movies.
我想是约翰·卡拉辛斯基讲的，说他曾经贬低过一部电影，要么是对着保罗·托马斯·安德森说的，要么就是在保罗·托马斯·安德森附近说的，然后保罗·托马斯·安德森把他拉到一边对他说：永远不要批评电影。
Like, especially, you know, in public.
尤其是，你知道的，在公开场合。
He said, even bad movies, people are trying to make something good and interesting.
他说，哪怕是烂片，人们也是在努力创作一些美好且有趣的东西。
People were so hard.
大家真的很不容易。
You got to follow the person's lead.
你得顺着对方的反应来。
If someone comes off stage and goes, didn't that show suck?
如果有人下台后说：刚才那演出是不是太烂了？
You can go like, well, you were great, but yeah, maybe, if the person comes off and doesn't offer that up, just you got to be like, go with God.
你可以说：嗯，你演得很棒，不过确实，也许……但如果那个人下台后根本没提这茬，那你只能顺其自然、听天由命了。
And there's probably a couple of people in your life that you should keep on tap, who are like, you'll give it to your straight.
生活中可能确实有那么几个人，你应该随时保持联系，他们会跟你说实话。
like you're my honesty people.
就像，他们是我的“直言不讳”智囊团。
But for the most part, I think like, you know, I mean, this was, this was stacked up for maximum, you know, this, we're getting into a more serious discussion about something that this episode actually doesn't exactly interrogate because Lily's play clearly sucked.
但在大多数情况下，我觉得，我的意思是，这些都是为了达到最大效果而故意堆砌的……你知道的，我们现在正在深入探讨一些本集并没有真正去剖析的东西，因为莉莉的剧确实烂透了。
Barney's play intentionally sucked.
巴尼的剧则是故意拍得很烂。
But I liked that Barney got a little sucked in.
但我喜欢巴尼有点被带进去的那种状态。
He actually cared about his performance and he's like, I, it's too many guys didn't get to see the end of it.
他其实很在乎自己的表演，他说，我……有太多人没看到结局了。
He like clearly wants to be able to finish his show, which I think I liked that moment, because that's the, even he wants to finish his stupid show, because goddamn it, he's come this far.
他显然很想把自己的演出演完，我觉得我挺喜欢那个时刻的，因为那就是……连他都想演完他那部愚蠢的剧，因为该死的，他都走到这一步了。
I liked that we showed that side.
我很喜欢我们展现出了他这一面。
And also, there's something about Barney that became clear.
而且，巴尼身上还有一点变得很清晰。
It's like, this is an aspect of his gambling addiction, which is that he has to win.
这就好比，这是他赌瘾的一个体现，那就是他必须赢。
He has to win.
他必须赢。
It's like they don't put money on it, but the bet is I can make you tell me this sucks, Lily.
这就好像他们没有拿钱下注，但赌注是：我能让你承认这很烂，莉莉。
Yeah, yeah, and he will not stop.
对，对，而且他会没完没了。
Yeah, it is, it is his gambling addiction.
对，这就是，这就是他的赌瘾。
He must win, that's really true, and he has to, but then he, I love that there's a little part of him that kind of loves his own show.
他必须赢，这真的很真实，他非赢不可，但随后，我喜欢他内心其实还有一小部分是挺喜欢自己的演出的。
Yeah.
对。
And then he gets slapped in the face by Marshall, so he gets his come up and it's like that.
然后他就被马歇尔当众扇了一巴掌，所以他得到了应有的报应，就是那种。
And there is no clearer review than slapping the face of a person performing.
没有什么比扇正在表演的人一巴掌更能说明问题的了。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, I love that Marshall ended that end of the show for Barney.
对，我喜欢马歇尔为巴尼的演出画上了这样一个句号。
I love that Ted gets pulled up for the curtain call, I love that he has to show.
我喜欢泰德被拉出来谢幕，我喜欢他不得不面对这一切。
There was something that is fun to play about like, I am, I don't want this to be happening, but I have to act like it's all okay.
那种感觉很有趣，就是去演绎：我根本不想经历这一切，但我还得装作一切都很好的样子。
Like, whenever you get to opposing things that kind of pull you apart, you know, that's always really fun to play.
你看，每当你面临两种相互拉扯、让你左右为难的对立情绪时，你知道的，演起来总是非常有意思。
When you have to wear a mask, you know, yes, yeah, totally, totally.
当你不得不戴着面具的时候，你知道的，是的，没错，完全是这样。
And that's what the whole episode's about, which I love.
而整集讲的就是这个，我非常喜欢。
And I think it's a good, it's a good Ted and Robin episode.
而且我觉得这是一集很好的泰德和罗宾的故事。
It kind of, it both moves their future forward a little bit and raises the stakes and they're going to live together now, which is a huge part of the episodes to come, but also shows you like a little bit of trouble, right?
它既让两人的未来稍微推进了一点，拉高了赌注——他们现在要住在一起了，这是接下来剧集的重要部分——同时也向你展现了一点点隐患，对吧？
There's a little bit of trouble rooming there, right?
同居生活里开始滋生一些小摩擦了，对吧？
It's definitely without spoilering anything.
绝对是这样，就不剧透了。
It foreshadows things to come at the end of the season.
它为这一季末尾将要发生的事情做好了铺垫。
I got to highlight a great needle drop.
我必须得重点夸一下这里绝妙的配乐插入。
I did not get into the stooges.
我以前并不迷“丑小子”乐队（The Stooges）。
I was not into the stooges at this moment in my life.
我人生中的这个阶段并不迷“丑小子”。
Carter and I love the stooges.
卡特和我很喜欢“丑小子”。
One of the best shows I've ever seen is Rebecca Carter and I went to see Iggy Pop at Irving Plaza in the 90s.
我看过最棒的演出之一，就是90年代我和丽贝卡、卡特一起去欧文广场看伊基·波普（Iggy Pop）的演出。
And he was at that point, you know, what it was in his 50s or whatever he was.
当时他已经，你知道的，五十多岁还是多少岁了。
And he gave the most fucking energetic punk rock show, you know, 25 years after, you know, when he would have been considered in his prime of that.
但他呈现了一场他妈的能量爆棚的朋克摇滚演出，你知道的，那可是在他被认为处于全盛期25年之后。
He is so raw.
他实在是太生猛了。
And that is like one of my favorite, um, Stooges songs, Reiki Pop songs.
那绝对是我最喜欢的……“丑小子”乐队的歌、伊基·波普的歌之一。
I want to be your dog.
《我想做你的狗》（I Wanna Be Your Dog）。
And the idea I got was so proud of it watching it last night with her back.
昨天晚上和贝卡一起看的时候，我油然而生一种骄傲感。
I said, no other CBS sitcom ever used a Stooges song.
我说，CBS没有任何其他的情景喜剧用过“丑小子”的歌。
That's It's essentially a song about like kind of S&M.
这本质上其实是一首关于某种S&M（虐恋）的歌。
Yeah.
对。
It basically is one that song.
基本上就是那一首。
So it's like a five o'clock.
所以就像是五点钟。
Also one cool thing about that song is like, you know how the hi-hat in drumming, like the hi-hat kind of keeps the tempo?
另外关于那首歌很酷的一点是，你知道打鼓时的踩镲（hi-hat）吗，踩镲有点像是在维持节奏？
In that song, if you listen to that song, the hi-hat part is a single piano note.
在这首歌里，如果你仔细听，踩镲的部分其实是一个单音钢琴键。
There's just one piano note going ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
只有一个钢琴键在“叮、叮、叮、叮、叮”地敲着。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
It's kind of like basically the hi-hat part, but it's as if the drummer is keeping time on one piano key, the ding, ding, ding.
它基本上起到了踩镲的作用，但听起来就像是鼓手在用一个琴键来打拍子，那个“叮、叮、叮”。
I love that about that song.
我很喜欢这首歌的这一点。
It's such a weird production choice.
这是一个非常诡异的制作选择。
I don't know if David Bowie, God, I should know that.
我不知道是不是大卫·鲍伊……天哪，我应该知道这个的。
I don't know if David Bowie produced it out or not, but it's just a really cool.
我不知道是不是大卫·鲍伊制作的，但这真的很酷。
Listen for that one piano note, and I want to be your dog, but- David Bowie produced Iggy Pops.
大家听听《我想做你的狗》里那个单音钢琴键，不过——大卫·鲍伊制作过伊基·波普的专辑。
He didn't do stooges.
他没做过“丑小子”的。
He did Iggy Pops, I think solo.
我想他做的是伊基的个人专辑。
He did Iggy solo, I think.
我想他做的是伊基的个人作品。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
But there's also something funny, like when you literalize it, when it's like, I want to be your dog, and then you see Robin walking five men with collars and leashes.
但也有搞笑的地方，比如当你把它字面化的时候，当歌词是“我想做你的狗”，然后你看到罗宾遛着五个戴着项圈和链子的男人。
It takes the entendre away.
这就把双关意境给消解了。
It makes it a single entendre song.
它变成了一首单关歌曲。
It's no longer about what it's- Something else is barely a double entendre in the song, but we still made it even less.
它不再是关于那种……歌里原本勉强算是个双关的东西，但我们把它变得更加直白了。
Yeah.
对。
It was a great great music choice Great needle drop.
这是个非常非常棒的音乐选择，绝佳的配乐切入。
I have really forgot that we did that and that should be on the list of like fucking cool music we put on like the stooges were on at 830 on CBS after King of Queens and before two and a half men and like a CSI.
我真的忘了我们用过这个，这绝对应该列入“我们用过的那些他妈超酷的音乐”清单里——“丑小子”乐队的歌竟然在晚上八点半的CBS播放，在《皇后区国王》之后、《好汉两个半》和某部《犯罪现场调查》之前。
Hey, did you ever read um this is a great book recommendation for anyone who's kind of interested in in the the punk scene in the 70s.
嘿，你读过……对于任何对70年代朋克圈感兴趣的人来说，这是一本极力推荐的好书。
Have you read Please Kill Me?
你读过《请杀死我》（Please Kill Me）吗？
I can't, Carton, Carter and I recommended to you because we read it like in our 20s that though.
我不行，卡特，卡特和我向你推荐过，因为我们二十多岁的时候就读过那本书。
Oh no, I didn't read it until like maybe eight or 10 years ago.
哦不，我直到大概八到十年前才读。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
Cause that's we, Carter turned me out of that book and then we would tell everybody about it.
因为那是……卡特向我安利了这本书，然后我们就把它推荐给所有人。
I don't know if you ever just, I love that book so much.
我不知道你是不是也这样，我太喜欢那本书了。
It's this great oral history, punk.
这是一本很棒的朋克口述历史。
Yeah, strong.
对，很有力量。
That book's incredible.
那本书太不可思议了。
It's an oral history.
这是一本口述历史。
It starts basically with Velvet Underground.
它基本上是从地下丝绒乐队（Velvet Underground）开始的。
It ends with sex pistols.
以性手枪乐队（Sex Pistols）结束。
Yeah, it sort of takes you through the whole chap, the whole movement.
对，它有点带你走过整个篇章，整个运动。
Yeah.
对。
But it's a great, starting at like Max's Kansas City, going to CBGB's, Patti Smith.
但它很棒，从Max's Kansas City开始，到CBGB's，帕蒂·史密斯（Patti Smith）。
Like it takes you through, it's almost like a great history of 70s New York, but told through the very specific lens of punk.
就像它带你经历的那样，它几乎是一部很棒的70年代纽约历史，但通过朋克这个非常独特的视角来讲述。
Absolutely, the Ramones.
没错，雷蒙斯乐队（Ramones）。
The Ramones, yeah.
雷蒙斯乐队，是的。
Another great book that my friend Lizzie Goodman wrote is called Meet Me in the Bathroom.
我的朋友莉兹·古德曼（Lizzie Goodman）写的另一本好书叫《在浴室里见我》（Meet Me in the Bathroom）。
Did you read that book?
你读过那本书吗？
No, I didn't.
不，我没读过。
It's kind of a spiritual secret.
它有点像是精神上的秘密续集。
to please kill me because it starts in 2001 to 2011, New York City starting with the strokes, through Vampire Weekend, LCD Sound System, DFA record, that whole thing.
致《请杀死我》（Please Kill Me），因为它从2001年一直写到2011年，纽约市从The Strokes（洞穴乐队）开始，历经Vampire Weekend（吸血鬼周末）、LCD Soundsystem（液晶声音系统）、DFA唱片，整个这一脉。
Like everyone thought like this isn't a scene, but she actually showed that there was something, you know, the yeah, yeah, yeah, as in TV on the radio, like there was so much going on in the moment.
就像每个人都觉得这不是一个流派，但她实际上展示了有些东西在发生，你知道的，Yeah Yeah Yeahs乐队，还有TV on the Radio，当时有那么多事情在发生。
So anyway, two great oral history books about New York City.
所以无论如何，这是两本关于纽约市的伟大的口述历史书籍。
Please kill me as the 70s.
《请杀死我》讲的是70年代。
me in the bathroom by Lizzy Goodman, 2001, 2011.
莉兹·古德曼写的《在浴室里见我》讲的是2001年到2011年。
I love a good oral history.
我很喜欢好的口述历史。
It's a great way to tell a story.
这是讲故事的一种好方法。
I know, it's a great, and it's like so readable because it's these little quotes and back and forth.
我知道，这太棒了，而且读起来非常引人入胜，因为里面都是这些短短的引言以及一来一回的对话。
I actually thought about, when I wrote my novel, my novel is like all these switching forward perspectives.
我其实想过，自我写小说以来，我的小说就是所有这些不断切换的前瞻视角。
And I thought about the obsessive readability of a book like Please Kill Me because you just need to keep turning the page because it's all these fascinating people.
我想到了像《请杀死我》这样一本书那令人欲罢不能的可读性，因为你只需不断翻页，里面全都是这些迷人的人物。
You're like, well, I can't stop here.
你会觉得，嗯，我不能在这里停下。
Iggy pops about to talk on the next page.
伊基·波普（Iggy Pop）马上就要在下一页发言了。
And after that, David Bowie says something and then Joey Ramone, it's so, it's great.
在那之后，大卫·鲍伊（David Bowie）说了一些话，然后是乔伊·雷蒙（Joey Ramone），太棒了，这太棒了。
It's like, it's a great like a bathroom read.
这就像是一本很适合在厕所里读的书。
So you're gonna read as much or as a little.
所以你可以读很多，也可以读一点。
Davey Jones in the Six is written as a kind of like fake oral history about a made up band.
《六人组中的戴维·琼斯》（Davey Jones in the Six）被写成了一种关于一支虚构乐队的假口述历史。
Oh, is it?
哦，是吗？
I didn't.
我不知道。
Yeah.
是的。
But it's a great way to tell a story.
但这是讲故事的一个好方法。
And, but yeah, so we've gone far afield.
而且，但是，是的，所以我们扯得太远了。
We've talked about the Stooges in Terminator 2 in this episode called Stuff.
我们在这一集名为《杂物》（Stuff）的节目里谈论了《三个臭皮匠》（The Stooges）和《终结者2》。
At least it's all cool.
至少这些都很酷。
You know what, the episode's called Stuff and we're just talking about a lot of stuff.
你知道吗，这一集叫《杂物》，而我们就是在谈论一大堆杂七杂八的东西。
We're just talking about stuff.
我们就是在闲聊各种杂物。
Before we go, I could just report in this directly from Kobe Smolders.
在我们离开之前，我可以直接从科比·斯墨德斯（Cobie Smulders）那里得到这个报道。
My guess is because there's no sound, we were just told where to go physically and made up the words.
我的猜测是因为没有声音，我们当时只是在物理层面上被告知去哪里，然后自己编台词。
So she also doesn't quite remember her.
所以她也记不太清了。
Did you just text her in real time about that question?
你刚才就那个问题实时发短信给她了吗？
Not only did I text her, but she didn't remember it at all.
我不仅发短信给她，而且她根本不记得了。
And I videoed the show now on Hulu on my side.
我还把Hulu上那段节目视频录下来发到了我这边。
Good to be honest.
说实话，真不错。
I sent her the clip, and that is the report that we just got it.
我把片段发给她了，这就是我们刚得到的报道。
Well, produced, my God.
制作得真好，天哪。
All right, so you guys were just making shit up?
好吧，所以你们当时只是在瞎编胡造？
I think there it is.
我想就是这样。
I think doing your own play.
我觉得是在演你们自己的烂戏。
You're on shitty play.
你们演的是一出烂戏。
A shitty play within the show about a shitty play.
剧里一出关于烂戏的烂戏。
You're doing your own half-baked play.
你们在演一出自己半生不熟的戏。
But it probably wasn't shitty.
但它可能并不烂。
It sounds like it was good.
听起来还挺不错的。
It was kind of good.
感觉还挺好的。
And I think it was kind of like, who needs writers?
而且我觉得当时的感觉就像是，谁需要编剧？
I think that was the feeling.
我想当时就是这种感觉。
Oh my God.
哦，天哪。
Like who needs writers?
就像谁需要编剧？
We can just- There's a great- This is brutal.
我们只需——这太残酷了。
Comp to that, during sandcastles in the sand where she is arguing where Kobe, and I believe Alan's sick.
与之相比，在《沙堡》（Sandcastles in the Sand）中，她和科比在争论，还有艾伦，我相信艾伦当时生病了。
Yeah, as her dad.
对，扮演她的爸爸。
Arguing over something.
在争论着什么。
And it was another silent argument.
那又是一场无声的争论。
it was a music video and it was filled with the end hysterical.
那是一个音乐录影带，里面充满了歇斯底里的情绪。
That's really funny.
那真的很有趣。
Yeah.
是的。
Welcome back.
欢迎回来。
So we, in this episode, stuff, episode 16 of season two of How I Make Mother, in our talk, Craig and I, we mentioned the movie Splash, the great Ron Howard, Tom Hanks, Derek, Hannah, comedy, we mentioned Terminator 2.
所以我们在这集《老爸老妈浪漫史》第二季第16集《杂物》中，在我们的交谈中，我和克雷格提到了电影《美人鱼》（Splash），伟大的朗·霍华德、汤姆·汉克斯、达丽尔·汉纳的喜剧，我们提到了《终结者2》。
And as we go through this, we're talking a lot about references that you and Carter and the writers were pulling from.
当我们回顾这些时，我们谈论了很多你、卡特和编剧们借鉴的梗。
I remember when you told me, I think after I got in cast, that you thought of Ted as a mix of Lloyd Dobler from Say Anything Meets George Bailey from It's a Wonderful Life.
我记得你告诉我，我想是在我被选角之后，你认为泰德（Ted）是《说点什么》（Say Anything）里的劳埃德·多布勒（Lloyd Dobler）和《生活多美好》（It's a Wonderful Life）里的乔治·贝利（George Bailey）的结合体。
Was that the mashup?
这就是两者的融合吗？
Absolutely.
绝对是的。
That's the mashup.
这就是两者的融合。
I think about it every year when I watch It's Wonderful Life, which I just did the other day with my kids.
我每年看《生活多美好》时都会想到这一点，前几天我还和我的孩子们一起看了。
My kids hadn't seen that.
我的孩子们以前没看过那个。
And I'm like, George Bailey, there's so much George Bailey and 10 minutes.
然后我说，乔治·贝利，短短10分钟里有那么多乔治·贝利的身影。
Yeah, well, also Christmas story.
对，还有《圣诞故事》（Christmas Story）。
I mean, we're, as artists, I think we're the, some of our references on some level, you know?
我的意思是，作为艺术家，我认为我们某种程度上就是我们所借鉴的东西的总和，你知道吗？
And I think as a writer, I know this, and I even did this as an actor a little bit.
我认为作为一个作家，我知道这一点，我甚至作为演员也稍微做过一点。
You imitate your heroes until your own voice and style comes through.
你模仿你的偶像，直到你自己的声音和风格显露出来。
You know, you, I tried to write like Philip Roth or Kenny Lonergan or, you know, like, I was trying to write like these people.
你知道的，我曾试图像菲利普·罗斯（Philip Roth）或肯尼·罗纳根（Kenneth Lonergan）那样写作，或者像这些人一样写作。
And then I get my own voice and same with you guys.
然后我找到了我自己的声音，你们也是一样。
And you know, this is airing I think in February, but we're a couple, we're a little bit ahead.
你知道，这集我想会在二月份播出，但我们的进度稍微超前了一点。
And my friend and my, someone we both, that meant so much to us artistically died, very tragically, Rob Reiner and his wife Michelle, a couple of days ago from when we were recording this.
我的朋友，以及对我们俩艺术生涯意义重大的人，在几天前我们录音的时候，非常不幸地去世了，罗伯·莱纳（Rob Reiner）和他的妻子米歇尔（Michelle）。
And I just wanted to kind of just have a couple of words about what his movies meant to both of us, just personally, and I just posted something on Instagram about this, but Rob cast me in a pilot for NBC called Everyday Life in 2003 or four, I can't remember, and the pilot was never picked up, but he directed it, he played my dad, Mercedes, who played my mom, it's about a family of therapists all live and work in the same brownstone.
我只想简单说几句话，谈谈他的电影对我们俩的个人意义，我刚刚在Instagram上发了关于这件事的帖子，罗伯在2003年或2004年（我记不清了）为NBC的一个试播集《日常生活》（Everyday Life）选了我，那个试播集虽然没被买下，但他导演了它，他扮演我的爸爸，梅赛德斯扮演我的妈妈，讲的是一个治疗师家庭都在同一栋褐石建筑里生活和工作的故事。
And it was all improvised and it was really wild and really fun.
这一切都是即兴创作，真的非常狂野也非常有趣。
And I got to know Rob and we had lunch over the years many times and he screened a cut of my second movie at his house with his wife and they gave me such beautiful feedback on it.
我有幸结识了罗伯，这些年来我们一起吃过很多次午餐，他在他家里和他的妻子一起放映了我的第二部电影的剪辑版，他们给了我非常美好的反馈。
And he was just a lovely, generous, passionate, beautiful man.
他是一个可爱、慷慨、充满激情的美好的人。
And he also made some of the greatest films ever.
而且他还拍了一些史上最伟大的电影。
I mean, truly like Pantheon films, you know, stand by me.
我的意思是，真的是神殿级的电影，你知道的，比如《伴我同行》（Stand by Me）。
This is Spinal Tap, the Princess Bride, when Harry Met Sally, Misery, a few good men.
《摇滚万岁》（This is Spinal Tap）、《公主新娘》（The Princess Bride）、《当哈利遇上萨利》（When Harry Met Sally）、《危情十日》（Misery）、《义海雄风》（A Few Good Men）。
Like, you can't believe that one director directed all of this.
简直让人难以置信，同一个导演竟然能执导所有这些作品。
It's astonishing.
这太令人惊叹了。
It's an astonishing achievement.
这是一个令人惊叹的成就。
Who else could do that?
还有谁能做到这一点？
I don't know any of it.
我对这些完全不了解。
It's the range of it.
厉害就厉害在它的涉猎范围之广。
And it was in the span of a few years.
而且这一切都在短短几年内完成。
Like he had a run that is just among the all time creative runs in the history of film.
就好像他的那段创作高峰期，简直是电影史上所有传奇创作期中的佼佼者。
I mean, it stands next to any other body.
我是说，它完全可以跟任何其他人的作品相媲美。
So what creative DNA do you think is Reiner-esque that found its way into how I met your mother?
那么，你觉得有哪些“雷纳式”的创作基因，最终融入到了《老爸老妈浪漫史》中呢？
I think you can make an argument that how I met your mother is essentially when Harry Metzali meets, stand by me meets the Princess Bride.
我觉得你可以这样认为，《老爸老妈浪漫史》基本上就是《当哈利遇到莎莉》、 《伴我同行》和《公主新娘》的结合体。
Because when Harry Metzali is the gold standard New York romantic comedy, right?
因为《当哈利遇到莎莉》是纽约浪漫喜剧的黄金标准，对吧？
I mean, there's just like, it's just untouchable.
我的意思是，它就像是……简直是不可逾越的经典。
And even within that movie, there is the framework of it's a story kind of being told.
即使在这部电影里，也有一种“故事正在被讲述”的框架。
All those couples you see, interspersed with, obviously Nora Afran wrote it beautifully, but I know she developed that whole project with Rob so collaboratively.
你看到的那些情侣们穿插其中，当然诺拉·埃夫伦写得非常精彩，但我知道她和罗布在开发整个项目时合作得极其紧密。
And then in like the Princess Bride, that idea of a story being told and popping in and out of the story, a story being told to a child by an older, wiser person and pop jumping in and out of the story, if you put that together with when Harry Met Sally, that's basically how I met your mother and stand by me having again that future narrator kind of making sense of, in that case, childhood, but remembering this beautiful chapter of his life that he's trying to capture as an adult in his middle age, who's played beautifully by Richard Dreyfus in the movie, God damn, that's how your mother all of those things are how much mother and then like the musical comedy piece like when Carter and I would write those Robin Sparkle songs what I would always look to was this is Spinal Tap because the songs that they did for the Spinal Tap they wrote them to be good songs.
然后在《公主新娘》里，那种故事正在被讲述、并在故事内外不断跳跃的概念——一个年长、更睿智的人把故事讲给一个孩子听，并在故事内外穿梭——如果你把这个与《当哈利遇到莎莉》结合起来，那基本上就是《老爸老妈浪漫史》了；而《伴我同行》也有那种未来旁白的感觉，在那部电影里，他是在理顺——当然那是关于童年的——但他在回忆自己人生的美好篇章，并在中年时以成年人的身份试图去捕捉它，电影里由理查德·德莱弗斯饰演得非常精彩，天哪，所有这些元素都构成了《老妈》；还有音乐喜剧的部分，当卡特和我创作那些罗宾·斯帕克兹的歌时，我一直效仿的对象就是《摇滚万岁》，因为他们为《摇滚万岁》创作的那些歌曲，本来就是作为好歌来写的。
Those are really really good songs.
那些歌真的是非常好非常好的歌。
They were so deadpan about what that movie was that they said the songs will be absurd but we're also going to make them great and there's something about, Reiner is like just control of tone, even within these incredibly diverse projects that he just knows what these things are, talk about these other DNA, like the DNA of those things, every molecule of those movies knows what movie they're in.
他们用极其一本正经的态度对待那部电影，他们说歌曲会很荒诞，但我们也要把它们做得非常动听；这就好比，罗布对基调有着绝对的把控，即使在这些极其多元的项目中，他也深知这些作品的本质。说到其他的基因，比如那些作品的基因，这些电影的每一个分子都清楚自己身处哪一部电影之中。
And that is coming through the singular vision of Ralph Reiner.
而这正是通过罗布·雷纳那独特的远见卓识展现出来的。
I loved him.
我太爱他了。
I love his work.
我热爱他的作品。
I never got to meet him.
我从未有机会与他会面。
I feel like I lost a friend and I never even met the man.
我感觉自己失去了一个朋友，尽管我甚至都没见过他本人。
And boy, his influence on everything and how much mother included is just beyond measure, he's just a brilliant man.
天哪，他对所有事物的影响——包括《老妈》在内——简直无法估量，他真的是个才华横溢的人。
Yeah, and I think also if you could distill or boil down what is a director's job, it's to make sure everyone's in the same movie that there's a kind of...
是的，而且我觉得如果你要提炼或归纳导演的工作是什么，那就是确保所有人都处在同一部电影里，确保有一种……
I read this thing that Tarantino, he made a movie actually before Reservoir Dogs that no one saw.
我读过一件事，昆汀在拍《落水狗》之前其实拍过一部没人看过的电影。
And he said, I made all my mistakes on that movie.
他说，我把所有的错误都在那部电影里犯光了。
I got all my mistakes out.
我把所有的错误都排解掉了。
Like I figured out, what do I think?
就像我弄清楚了，我的想法是什么？
I never knew that.
我以前根本不知道这些。
And he said to someone early on, like, I don't know what a light has seen.
他早期对某个人说，比如，我不知道灯光该怎么看。
I don't know how to frame a shot.
我不知道该怎么构图。
And they said, yeah, as an photographer does that, you just have to keep the story in mind and make sure that everything that's showing up on screen is in service to your vision of the story.
然后对方说，是的，摄影师会做那些，你只需要把牢故事，确保银幕上呈现的一切都是为了服务于你对故事的愿景。
And I think Rob was an absolute master at, like you said, because you stack those all up against each other.
我觉得罗布绝对是这方面的宗师，就像你说的，因为你把这些作品一一对比。
You could probably isolate certain themes that recur.
你可能会挑出一些反复出现的特定主题。
You know, I mean, there is a notion of like true love, love wins the day, you know, the value in both friendship and also, and also seeing how friendship and how love evolves over time.
你知道，我的意思是，这里面有一种真爱的理念，真爱战胜一切，你知道，友谊的价值，以及看到友谊和爱情如何随着时间推移而演变。
When Harry Met Sally is astonishing the economy of storytelling, it almost could be a nine-year run of watching Harry and Sally find their way to each other, but he does it in two hours.
《当哈利遇到莎莉》的叙事经济性令人震惊，花九年时间看哈利和莎莉如何走到一起完全说得通，但他用两个小时就完成了。
There's no fat on it.
里面没有任何臃肿多余的东西。
It's just like, it's incredibly efficiently done.
它就像是……执行得极其高效。
Yeah, and that's part of his brilliance.
是的，这也是他的高明之处。
It's just knowing what the story needs and not going past that, not never losing sight of that.
那就是清楚故事需要什么，绝不超出那个范畴，永远不会忘却这一点。
I know Carter, too, is just an enormous, enormous fan.
我知道卡特也是他的超级超级大粉丝。
And when we pitched the pilot, when we pitched Time With The Mother as a series, I guarantee you every time we pitched it, we referenced the Princess Bride and the future, and essentially Peter Fogg telling the story.
当我们推销试播集时，当我们把《老爸老妈浪漫史》作为一个剧集向电视台推销时，我向你保证，每一次我们推销的时候，我们都会提到《公主新娘》和未来，以及本质上彼得·福克讲故事的方式。
I like, and when Harry Metzali, this is how we pitched the show.
我喜欢，还有《当哈利遇到莎莉》，这就是我们推销这部剧的方式。
We pitched the show using Rob, And also the Princess Bride tells this kind of mythic fairy tale, but also narrator's head is pitching a kind of mythic fairy tale about his 20s and 30s in New York.
我们用罗布来推销这部剧，而且《公主新娘》讲述了一种神话般的童话故事，但旁白的脑海里其实也在构思一个关于他在纽约的20多岁和30多岁的神话般的故事。
And Stan by me has that feeling too, like it's a fable, it's his writer's life, but it's how we all write our memories, right?
《伴我同行》也有那种感觉，就像是一个寓言，那是他身为作家的生活，但这不正是我们所有人书写记忆的方式吗？
We keep writing and refining our memories.
我们一直在书写和雕琢我们的记忆。
And I think he had, you know, you can see this from his dedication to politics, to free speech like he was an incredibly passionate man who also believed like we could be better.
而且我觉得他拥有……你知道的，从他对政治、对言论自由的执着中就能看出，他是一个极具激情的人，他也坚信我们可以变得更好。
Yes.
是的。
You know, there was something in his movies that was aspirational in the best sense of the word.
你知道，他的电影里有一种积极向上的精神，是那种最好的意义上的积极向上。
I felt like even though you could definitely glean a through line of deep optimism, it was a hard-earned optimism, my favorite kind.
我觉得，尽管你绝对能从中梳理出一条贯穿始终的深沉乐观主义，但那是一种历经磨难才得来的乐观，也是我最喜欢的那种。
It was a realist's optimism, but it was definitely like there were headed someplace better.
那是现实主义者的乐观，但它绝对是在表达——我们在朝更好的方向前进。
Yes.
是的。
Let's leave our characters better than we found them.
让我们让笔下的角色离开时变得比我们刚发现他们时更好。
Yes, that's right.
是的，没错。
That's right.
没错。
Let's let's evolve.
让我们进化吧。
Let's grow.
让我们成长吧。
And he was a curious kind of searching mind and heart that man.
那个男人有着一颗充满好奇、不断探索的心灵和灵魂。
It was so clear in his life and his work that we was.
这一点在他的生活和工作中是如此显而易见，我们确实如此。
I didn't know that I didn't remember, I guess, that you acted in that pilot with him.
我不知道……我大概不记得你和他在那个试播集里演过对手戏了。
He played my dad.
他演了我爸爸。
I forgot that.
我把这事给忘了。
I knew it was sort of him and he directed it.
我知道是类似他出演并且他执导的。
I forgot you acted in scenes with him.
我忘了你曾和他一起演过对手戏。
That's so cool.
这太酷了。
Yeah, of course.
对，当然。
It was the season right before how I made mothers that it was just the pilot.
那是《老爸老妈浪漫史》开拍前的那个季，当时只有试播集。
Just the pilot didn't get picked up by NBC.
只有试播集，没有被NBC买下。
But you got to act in scenes with with Rob Reiner who was also directing it.
但你竟然能和身兼导演的罗布·雷纳演对手戏。
That's an incredible experience, man.
这真的是段不可思议的经历，老兄。
And I told this story in my Instagram post, but I'll just tell it to you now, but he was kind of behind the monitor and I was kind of lurking and talking to him a little bit.
我在Instagram的动态里讲过这个故事，不过我现在再跟你讲一遍，当时他坐在监视器后面，而我在周围转悠，跟他聊了一会儿。
And he turned to me and he said, I'm nervous.
他转过身对我说：“我很紧张。”
And I said, you still get nervous?
我说：“你现在还会紧张？”
I thought like, why is he nervous for this pilot?
我当时想，他为什么会为这个试播集紧张？
Have you seen?
你难道没见过……？
And he said, if you're not nervous on the first day of shooting, it's time to leave the business, you know?
然后他说：“如果你在开机第一天不紧张，那就是时候离开这个行业了，你知道吗？”
Like nerves to him were a real sign.
对镇定对他来说是一个真正的信号。
You still cared so much.
说明你依然在乎得不得了。
He still has seen it in the game and it was, his heart was in it.
说明他依然全身心投入在这场游戏中，他的心始终在其中。
His heart was in everything he did, including that.
他的心投入在他所做的每一件事中，包括那部作品。
It clings so deep into his career.
这深深地烙印在他的职业生涯中。
He still was in it.
他依然全身心地投入其中。
I love that story and that says everything.
我很喜欢这个故事，这说明了一切。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
He just loved making things and he was a great collaborator and he was, he was truly, he offered himself as a mentor to me in a lot of ways.
他就是热爱创造事物，他是个伟大的合作伙伴，而且他……他真的在很多方面都主动担任了我的导师。
You know, we, for a couple of years there, we were having lunch once a year or so And he was, you know, often with his producer, producing partner, Alan Greisman is a great guy who also produced that show.
你知道，在那之后的几年里，我们大约一年吃一次午餐，而且通常还有他的制片人搭档艾伦·格赖斯曼，他是个超级棒的家伙，也制作了那部剧。
And they were just really kind to me.
他们对我都真的非常好。
And I'll never forget him inviting me over to the house to screen the cut of liberal arts.
我永远不会忘记他邀请我去他家观看《文科恋曲》的剪辑版。
And he cast me in that pilot when I was, I don't know, 28, 29, 27, maybe, I don't know.
在我大概……不知道吧，28、29、27岁左右的时候，他选我出演了那个试播集，记不清了。
But I was a couple of years out of grad school.
但我当时刚从研究生院毕业几年。
I think I had been on Broadway in the graduate and I'd gotten fired from my first pilot.
我想我当时刚演完百老汇的《毕业生》，而且我刚被我的第一个试播集剧组开除。
The second series didn't work.
第二个剧集没成功。
The third pilot season, I tested like 10 times and didn't get anything.
第三个试播集季，我试镜了大概10次却什么都没拿到。
And so this was like my fourth pilot season, maybe fifth pilot season.
所以这大概是我的第四个试播集季，也许是第五个试播集季。
And I don't know, just to be able to like, there are these moments, like maybe you felt this way about Letterman, Craig, but where, when you tell your parents who cast you or what you're doing, they get it.
我不知道，能够拥有这样的时刻——也许你对莱特曼、克雷格也有这种感觉——当你告诉父母是谁选角录用了你，或者你在做什么时，他们能懂。
Like your parents in Long Island, your parents in Ohio, they get it.
就像你在长岛的父母，你在俄亥俄州的父母，他们懂。
Like my parents grew up watching all in the, you know, they watched all in the family.
就像我的父母从小看着……你知道的，他们看《一家子》。
They watched and loved all those movies.
他们看过并喜爱所有那些电影。
So when I got to say Rob Reiner cast me in a pilot for NBC, they also knew what NBC was, there was something that that we, it was important moment for me.
所以当我能说“罗布·雷纳选我出演了NBC的一个试播集”时——他们也知道NBC是什么——这其中有一种……对我来说是个重要的时刻。
It's important, I know what you mean.
这很重要，我明白你的意思。
It's important.
这很重要。
I have a real job.
我有份真正的工作。
I'm really doing this because this person believes in me.
我这么做其实是因为这个人相信我。
Yeah, and I remember I shot the pilot and my grandfather died before I got the news.
对，我记得我拍了试播集，在我得知消息前我爷爷去世了。
I actually got the news.
我其实是那时候听到消息的。
It wasn't picked up the day of my grandfather's funeral, but my dad said something really kind of sweet.
虽说节目没有在我爷爷葬礼那天被买下，但我爸说了一句挺贴心的话。
He said, well, your grandpa went to his death thinking you were doing a show for NBC with Rob Reiner, like, that's okay, that's okay.
他说，你爷爷到死都以为你要和罗伯·莱纳一起为NBC做一档节目呢，这挺好的，挺好的。
That was good for him to feel into that.
他能这样想，对他也算是个安慰。
And it was just like, there are these moments, maybe we've talked about this, but there are these moments as an artist, as a young actor or writer where you lose faith in yourself.
当时我就觉得，会有那么一些时刻——也许我们讨论过这个——作为一名艺术家，作为一个年轻的演员或编剧，你对自己的信心会动摇。
it's natural.
这很自然。
Is this going to happen for me?
这会发生在我身上吗？
Oh, it's happening for that guy.
哦，那家伙的的机会来了。
Why isn't it happening for me or her?
为什么机会不降临在我或者她身上？
And then there are these people that come along and say, hey, we need you.
然后就会出现这样一些人，他们对你说，嘿，我们需要你。
We'd like you.
我们看中你了。
You're the guy.
你就是那个人。
You're the one for this.
你就是做这个的不二人选。
And Rob came along at a moment that I needed someone to believe in me, like him.
罗伯就在我最需要有人相信我的时候出现了，就像他那样。
I needed Rob Reiner.
我当时真的需要罗伯·莱纳。
It was great that it was actually Rob Reiner.
而且那个人真的是罗伯·莱纳，这太棒了。
I got the actual guy to say, and I remember auditioning for him.
我居然让本尊对我说……我记得当时为他试镜。
and I remember making him laugh.
我记得我把他逗笑了。
I remember there was a great, funny comedian actress who played my wife, Mary Gallagher, and we were improvising at the, I think at the network, like it was our network test, and he was kind of interviewing us, and maybe he was playing the couples therapist essentially, like we were in couples therapy.
我记得当时有一位很棒、很搞笑的女喜剧演员玛丽·加拉格尔演我的妻子，我们在——我想是在电视台——进行即兴表演，就像是我们的电视台试播测试一样，他当时在某种程度上采访我们，也许他基本上是在扮演婚姻治疗师的角色，就像我们在做婚姻咨询一样。
And she was like, I don't wanna do anything crazy fancy for the wedding, you know?
然后她说，你知道的，我不想为婚礼搞得那么花里胡哨的。
And she wanted this like kind of hippie wedding.
她想要那种有点嬉皮士风格的婚礼。
And I was like, my mom, my parents are not gonna, like, and they're like, well, where do you want to get married?
而我说，我妈，我爸他们可不会……然后他们问，那你们想在哪儿结婚？
And I was like, Chippurianis, which is like the most fancy place you could get married in New York City.
我说，Cipriani's，那是纽约市最豪华的结婚地点。
Like, it's like, you know, it's absurd how aristocratic it is.
你知道的，它那种贵族气息简直荒谬。
But I knew, I knew Chippurianis because I think like an ex girlfriend's friend had gotten married there.
但我知道，我知道Cipriani's是因为我记得好像哪个前女友的朋友在那里结过婚。
But Rob knew Chippurianis and he almost fell out of his seat, you know, it was like the perfect thing.
但罗伯知道Cipriani's，他差点从椅子上摔下来，你知道的，这就完美了。
I think it got me the job that I knew.
我想就是因为我知道这个，我才得到了这份工作。
I can't imagine the satisfaction of knowing you made a murder.
我无法想象那种知道自己逗笑了一个大佬的满足感。
Yeah.
对。
Like really laugh.
就是真的笑出来。
Like what?
那种感觉？
That's, that's, you'll always have that moment.
那是，那是，你永远都会铭记那个时刻。
Yeah.
对。
That's amazing.
太惊艳了。
And he was also, he was also, um, you know, some funny people don't laugh.
而且他也是，他也是……你知道，有些搞笑的人自己反而不笑。
Yes.
对。
Oh, yeah.
哦，对。
Oh, he was a funny person who laughed.
哦，他是一个会笑的有趣的人。
So you fell.
所以你感受到。
I know.
我懂。
He's so well.
他太棒了。
He felt his work and felt his generosity.
他感受到了他的工作，也感受到了他的慷慨。
I also felt him wanting us to do well.
我也能感觉到他希望我们表现出色。
We were clearly the ones he want.
我们显然就是他想要的人。
I think we were there.
我想我们当时就在那儿。
We were the only ones who tested.
我们是唯一试镜的人。
Like he wanted it to be us.
就好像他希望那个人就是我们。
us.
我们。
He created an environment where we could do our best work.
他创造了一个能让我们发挥出最佳水平的环境。
So, you know, it's also, it's a strange thing.
所以，你知道，这也是一件很奇妙的事。
I made this thing with him.
我和他一起做过这个项目。
We worked together for a couple weeks.
我们一起合作了几个星期。
No one ended up seeing it except some NBC executives who said we're going to pass on this.
结果除了几个NBC高管说“我们要放弃这个项目”之外，谁也没能看到它。
So it's not like I have this big document of like, this is what we made together.
所以并不是说我手里有什么宏大的资料证明“这就是我们一起创作的东西”。
I think I saw one cut of it or something and it was like, I'm just moved on and then I did how I met your mother in the next year.
我想我大概看过它的一个剪辑版之类的，然后我就继续前行了，第二年我拍了《老爸老妈的浪漫史》。
But yeah, I am forever grateful that he, he said, he pointed and said, you, I'm I'm grateful I got to spend some time with him.
但无论如何，我永远感激他，他当时指着我说了“你”。我很感激能和他共度一些时光。
I'm grateful for those lunches and I'm grateful that those movies live on and inspired us and inspired people even that didn't know him.
我很感激那些午餐，也很感激那些电影得以长存，激励了我们，也激励了那些甚至不认识他的人。
Yeah, but you know, I can attest just personally that he was just a wonderful dude and he was a great talent and he was also a real mench and I miss him.
对，但你知道，我可以亲证他真的是一个绝佳的家伙，他才华横溢，而且也是个性情中人，我真的很想念他。
And I'm so, it's so heartbreaking that he was denied the happy ending that he gave so many of his characters and so.
而且我感到非常痛心，他竟然未能拥有他曾赋予那么多角色的那种美满结局。
Yeah, that's a lot of love for you, Rob, and Michelle, and just wishing his family and his loved ones the best.
是的，我们对你充满爱意，罗伯、米歇尔，并祝愿他的家人和挚爱一切都好。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《老爸老妈的浪漫史》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人，由Office Ladies网络和Audacy呈献并发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利担任执行制片人。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matata.
节目由我亚历克·莱夫制作和剪辑，我们的联合制作人是道格·马塔塔。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是Point of Blue工作室的亚历克斯·里夫斯。
Our digital content producer aka Gen Z Master is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，也就是Z世代大师是艾米莉·布隆伯格。
artwork by John Morrow.
封面艺术由约翰·莫罗创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在Apple Podcasts或您首选的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作的《纽约市》，附加音乐由克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基提供。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajormother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
访问 HowWeMajormother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
请在Substack上订阅乔什·拉德纳的通讯，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐及其他内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasRider.com.
在各大图书销售点订购克雷格·托马斯的小说处女作《事情可不是这样的》，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上查看他发表的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
您也可以在Substack上订阅我自己的“死去的父亲协会”。
To learn more about how you make a difference, This shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解更多关于如何为先天性小儿心脏病研究筹集资金的持续公益活动贡献力量，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签页。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，它会跳舞。